[Music]
hey folks today
we are gonna build this plug-in from
scratch using modern c-plus plus
and the juice framework in this free
course check the description for links
to the repository and to download the
final build
okay what is this thing this is the
little brother of this
other plugin which is my new course for
pfm c
plus four musicians which is where you
can build this other plugin
which is also where you can learn modern
c plus and the juice framework from
scratch taught from the context of
writing audio software
in a mentored environment you're not
following videos you're not watching
someone else code and you're not copying
them
you're coding it yourself and i'm
reviewing your work
all right enough about those let's learn
about what we are going to build
today this is a 3-band equalizer with a
spectrum analyzer at the top
it has a low-cut band it has a high cut
band and has a parametric band in the
middle
the low-cut band lets you cut out all of
the low end of the signal
you can also control the steepness of
the cut
the high cut band lets you remove all
the high frequencies
and you can also control how steep that
cut is
the parametric band lets you add notches
or boosts
and we can also control how wide or how
narrow those boosts are and we can
control the frequency
everybody's familiar with this type of
swept frequency sound
above that there are bypass buttons
which allow you to disable individual
bands which is always helpful when
you're working on audio
and above that is the response curve
which gives us a visual representation
of what the filters are doing then
behind that
is the spectrum analyzer and this shows
us what we are hearing
and these always use a bunch of cpu so
there's a bypass button for that as well
we're going to learn all the dsp that's
going on in the background
that makes this thing work we're going
to learn how to draw everything how to
draw the sliders the bypass buttons how
to draw the response curve and make it
respond
whenever we adjust the sliders and how
to draw the spectrum analyzer
okay that's the feature set for this
plugin and for this free course
my name is chuck i go by the name matcat
music on youtube and instagram
once again check the description for
links to the repository
and to download the final build of this
plugin so let's get started
and write some audio software using
modern c plus plus and the juice
framework
from scratch
[Music]
all right the first thing we need to do
is get set up with the juice framework
now if you've never done any audio
programming before fear not
the only things you need are two tools
the juice framework and then an ide to
write code in
that could be xcode or it could be
visual studio it depends on what
operating system you're running i'm on
mac so i'm going to be using xcode for
this video
if you've never set yourself up with an
ide before
i have two videos linked in the
description they take you through the
process
of setting up your computer with an ide
getting the juice
framework setting up producer setting up
a git repository
making your first project and then um
pushing changes to that
and um yeah it basically gets you
familiar with the flow
with the workflow that goes in with
being a software developer
in the context of writing audio software
okay so the first thing we're going to
do is go get the juice framework so
let's do that
right now i'm going to open up safari
because that's
just um this is like just a blank os
install
and i'm gonna install um i'm gonna grab
juice so juice
framework just gonna search for it it is
hosted on github
so i'm gonna go grab it here now what
i'm going to do is i'm going to clone
the repository and the reason is because
um this is an active repository they
make a lot of changes to it okay
so especially on the develop branch we
want to make sure that we have all of
these changes because stuff's getting
fixed all the time
features are being added that sort of
thing so if i have
the repository cloned i'm able to pull
in those changes
this is different from if i had just
downloaded a zip file
so that's why i'm going to do that okay
i'm going to go to terminal
if you don't have terminal open just you
know terminal open it like that or open
some kind of command
prompt shell okay then i'm going to uh
let's see i've got my
um my users folder right here and i'm
just going to clone the repository right
into that so
git clone and then the url
just like that that's going to make the
juice folder and it's going to download
this repository
into this folder and it's in it's going
to include all of the commit changes as
well so let's just wait for this to
finish
all right there it goes there's the
juice framework now
what we want to do is switch to the
develop branch because as i had shown it
is
um more it contains more recent changes
than the other branch you can see that
the develop branch is
19 commits ahead of the master branch so
to do that we need to
type in terminal uh first we need to go
into the juice folder
so let's do that right now cd juice
dot slash juice and now we need to do
git
check out develop like that
all right switch to a new branch develop
okay cool now i prefer to use a git gui
so i'm going to be using fork from now
on in the course of this
simple eq that we will be building so
i'm going to open that now so we can see
what this repository looks like in that
sense
so i'm going to open up fork fork is
available from fork.dev
okay so here is the repository i had
already added it previously
um and you can see here's all the
commits that have been added
and all the basically all the work that
they've been doing on it and you can see
how frequently they update
the develop branch okay our next job is
to
open up producer and use
producer to make a project pro juicer is
found in the extras folder
inside producer now inside here you're
going to find a builds folder
and in there is a project file for each
operating system you got
linux you got mac and you got windows so
if you're on windows open the solution
file
depending on which version of visual
studio you're running if you're on mac
you're going to open up the xcode file
if you're on linux there's a make file
and you linux users know what to do with
make files
so i'm not going to talk about that okay
i'm going to open up producer
the solution file that's going to open
up xcode and now all i need to do is
just build and run
okay so we just need to wait for this to
happen
apologies if i start speaking fast
i like doing this stuff a lot and when i
get excited i start to speak really fast
so if i happen to
speak too fast i'm probably gonna take a
step back and repeat what i say
slower so just apologies in advance if i
start speaking really really fast
all right so let's wait for this to
finish building build succeeded
now it's going to run it and then we
will be able to configure
uh this stuff all right so let's get
this set up
okay we are presented with the new
project wizard
before we do that we want to go to
producer and we want to configure our
global paths
and these need to point to the juice
folder
and the modules folder now the juice
folder by default if you clone the
repository to your users folder
this stuff is going to be set
automatically it's going to go right to
your users folder and the juice thing
however if you decide to put it
somewhere else you need to customize
these modules so click on this button
right here
and then navigate to wherever your juice
folder is stored
for setting the path to juice then do
the same thing for the modules
click click that button navigate to your
juice folder and then navigate to the
modules button to the modules folder
inside of that
okay and then if you rescan it'll tell
you if there's any issues or not
once that is done now you can go to the
plug-in right here
basic and we're going to create a
project called
simple eq and then we can do create
project and it's going to ask me where
do i want to save this
create project i want to save it to this
programming folder
and there it goes it's going to save it
it's going to make it and now if i
reveal in finder
here is my project so i'm going to make
a git repository next before i actually
take a look
around at the code because it's always
important to set yourself up with the
git repository
in case you have to backtrack and undo
some stuff or whatnot
so i'm going to do that next all right
so in the interest
of keeping everything neutral i will not
be creating the repository in fork
but i will be doing it in terminal
because everybody's computer has a shell
it may not have fork in it
so what i need to do is first navigate
to the folder that my repository is in
so i'm going to do that cd i'm just
going to drag this folder in here
now i'm inside that folder and now i'm
going to do git init
like that okay now uh i'm not seeing it
so i'm gonna turn on
um hidden files and now here is my git
repository okay
so what i need to do next is create
a i need to do an initial commit and
commit the state of this
now i do not want to include everything
that's in this builds folder
and i do not want to include uh
everything that's in this juice library
folder
because a juice library code folder
because every time we resave
this producer file it recreates these
folders the only thing we want to keep
is
the juicer file and the source file so
i'm going to add a git init file
first or a git ignore file sorry so i
will do
touch dot get dot get egg
nor like that that creates a document
which i can open with a text editor
and specify that i want to exclude this
builds folder
and this juice library code so let me go
do that i'm going to open this with uh
i'm going to open it with text edit
that's fine
and i want to write star star slash
builds
caps star star slash juice oops
library code okay that's the name of
these two folders
and then uh because this is os x i'm
going to do
star star slash dot d s underscore store
like that
we're not seeing any of those files
right now but
sometimes we will that's um basically
it's
the if i can figure how this folder
looks um it's gonna get stored as a ds
store file
and those are super annoying to include
um in your repository so it's very good
to keep them excluded
okay next i'm going to do
git um let's see git commit dash
m this is my initial commit let's do a
git status first
let's see what we got get status we can
see that there are no tracked files so
let's add
our files git add and you'll notice that
it's
the untracked files does not include
anything in the builds folder and the
juice
library code folder and that's because
of the git ignore file it's doing its
job
let me just move this out of here so you
can see what i'm talking about
so if i do that again um let's see let's
do um
get status we can see we've got these
new files here
but it's also not tracking these guys so
there is a ds store somewhere
there's a builds folder and there's a
juice library code okay
as i said before we don't want those
included so i'm going to put that back
and then we'll do git status one more
time okay so we've got our git ignore
the juicer file and then the four source
code files all right now that we have
those
ready to be committed let's make a
commit git commit dash
m initial commit
whoops i forgot the closing quote all
right
that's fine good enough okay now i can
open this
in fork i can do file open repository
so now i can actually see what's going
on
and here's right here's my initial
commit all right good times
okay so if we want we can go make a
repository on github and push the code
there
um or you know just keep it local but
either way now we can keep track of
everything
okay so i'm going to give you a quick
overview of where everything happens in
the source code now
before we actually start work on this
okay
so this is going to be a brief overview
of how these plugins work and um
what where we will primarily be spending
most of our time
doing edits in the code so we have four
source files right here we've got
plug-in processor.cpp pluginprocessor.h
plugineditor.cpp and plugineditor.h
in uh let me pull up the assistant
editor
so that we can see what's going on on
both sides okay
plugin processor.h um in a juice plugin
you've got two main functions that are
the most important
there's your prepare to play function
and then there is your process block
function
prepare to play gets called by the host
when it's about to start playback
and then process block is actually what
happens whenever
you hit the play button in the transport
control when you hit that play button
the host just starts sending buffers at
a regular rate into your plug-in and
it's your plug-ins job to
give it back any finished audio that is
done processing
you cannot interrupt that chain of
events
if you add latency or whatever it can
cause clicks and pops in your speakers
and
that has the potential to damage
speakers as well as explode eardrums
just imagine this scenario that you're
at a club and the sound system is super
loud
and your plug-in causes a pop or a
glitch
the sound you know the sound engineer or
the dj or whatever has their thing
totally cranked and
there's this huge pop and everybody's
ears just go
like that so that's why um that's the
big thing about audio processing is you
can't
um interrupt this process block and
anything that goes on inside it you have
to just kind of
um you got to figure out how to get all
the all the work that you need done by
your code
done within a fixed amount of time okay
so those are the two big functions we're
going to be spending most of our time
with prepare to play
and then process block now um let's take
a look at what happens over there so in
prepare to play
use this as the place to do any
pre-playback initialization that you
need
and then in process block this is where
you get your actual block of audio data
um and if you're using a midi controller
these are where the midi messages are
but basically um this is where we do all
of the work we're gonna be
typing all a bunch of code here and we
have to make sure that it um
doesn't happen in like more time than we
have been allotted
okay let's go take a look at plugin
editor now plugin editor
is where we set up all of our visual
elements and um there's some basic stuff
you got your basic constructor
you got your paint function your resized
function
uh painting you know it's what we're
gonna see right now we're
showing a hello world if i run this real
quick
so before i get into showing how to run
it um
yeah right now we're just going to see a
hello world displayed at the center of
the screen
um and then if we have any child
components like buttons or
sub components or anything like that
we'll lay them out here in the resized
function
okay so that's a basic overview we're
going to be basically making child
components to represent the knobs and
the sliders
and the spectrum analyzer and the
response curve
and then we're going to be you know
drawing them in there based on
some you know audio parameters that
we've got
okay so let's run this for the first
time what we need to do is go to
our particular scheme we have a few
targets we've got a vst3 format
we have an audio unit format if we are
on os x and then we have the standalone
version
okay so i'm going to put this on
standalone
in visual studio you'll do something
similar you will set the
target to run to be the standalone
version and then
all we need to do is just run it build
and run it's going to compile these four
files it's going to compile any module
files that are being used
all right here's our standard plug-in
it's not doing anything it's just
displaying hello world but it is
processing audio
so yeah that's it there's our basic
plugin we're going to turn this into
the thing i showed at the very beginning
i wanted to add a quick note right
before we get started writing actual
code
what you need to do is go to producer
click on this gear right now for the
project
click on this gear scroll down and you
need to change the
language type to be c plus plus
17 okay a lot of the stuff we're going
to be using this involves c
plus plus 17. okay once you've done that
just click save and open in ide
all right let's start coding navigate to
the audio
to the plugin processor.h file because
we need to declare some variables
audio plugins depend on parameters to
control the various parts of the dsp
juice uses an object called the audio
processor value tree state
to coordinate syncing these parameters
with the knobs on the gui and the
variables in the dsp
so we need one of these in our audio
processor and it needs to be public so
the gui
can attach all of its knobs and sliders
and buttons and combo boxes and stuff to
it
all right so let's declare one of those
all right we need to give it a name i'm
just going to call it ap vts
and then we need to make sure that we
use curly braces here
not parameter not parentheses when we
declare it
all right uh the audio processor to
connect to is going to be this
audio processor we are not going to use
an a
an undo manager uh we're going to just
call it
parameters and then we need to provide
a function here to give us a parameter
layout so the ap vts expects us to
provide the list of all parameters
when it is created so we need a function
that will provide that for us
in the form of an ap vts parameter
layout
so let's create that now
all right and we can just call it and
actually let's make it static
since it doesn't use any member
variables and i have an extra colon
okay let's declare this guy right here
now for this project we will keep the
dsp and the gui simple
we are only going to have three
equalizer bands
low cut high cut and peak for the low
cut and high cut bands we will be able
to control the frequency cutoff as well
as the
slope of the cut off for the peak or
parametric band we will be able to
control the center frequency
the gain and the quality meaning how
narrow or how wide
the peak is all right so we will start
with the low cut and high cut frequency
parameters
and juice has an audio processor
parameter class
and let me pull up the documentation for
this real quick actually
all right so juice has an audio
processor parameter class
this class is a generic interface
towards all the different audio
parameter formats that different plug-in
hosts use
for example audio unit on os x
is used by apps like logic or final cut
or garage band
vst 3 on windows and osx is used
in apps like cubase or ableton live
reaper
or bit wig and then there's aax
for pro tools okay now the audio
processor parameter class has several
derived types
that represent things like sliders and
switches and combo boxes
and for our needs the audio parameter
flow type is used to represent
parameters that should be represented on
the gui with a slider
of some kind so we want our frequency
range to be adjustable
over a wide range so we are going to use
an audio parameter float
for this so let's declare
our let's declare one of these
and i hope the font is big enough for
you to be able to see what's going on
we're going to return our layout
and now we can now we can add
um an audio parameter float to this so
like out dot let's see
add and these things want unique
pointers so we'll use uh make unique for
this
make unique and we want a juice
audio parameter float we want that guy
all right the name of this is going to
be low cut
freak the parameter name will also be
low
cut freak um the normalizable range is
the next part
now the human ear has a range of roughly
you can pick up sounds from 20 hertz to
20 000 hertz
so that will define the range for our
parameter let's uh create one of these
oops normalizable range here's the
where's the one that has
that takes parameters this is the one
that we want okay
uh we're going to make it use type float
okay now the
range start is going to be 20 and the
range end is going to be 20
000. now the interval value we're going
to use a
interval value of 1 and what that means
is that our slider will change the
parameter's value in steps of
one we could use bigger steps if we
wanted to for example we could drag the
slider
um if this was set to 10 then our slider
would
go from like 20 to 30 to 40 to 50 every
time we drag it
but as we get in the upper uh range
of frequencies that could be helpful
more than this lower range
the audible effects of like 20 hertz
versus 25 hertz like they sound like
different notes on the piano
whereas 2000 to 2050 does not really
sound like different notes on the piano
so we're going to keep this at a step
size of 1.
okay the skew factor now the skew
parameter lets us change how the slider
responds what that means is that we can
skew the slider such that the majority
of our mouse movements
are covering the lower part of this
parameters range
for example i'm reading my notes over
here
for example i could set this skew value
such that 75
of the sliders range covers the values
20 hertz through
1000 hertz leaving the last 25 percent
of the sliders range
to cover the remaining frequencies one
thousand and one hertz to
twenty thousand hertz or i could skew it
differently so that the slider's bottom
ten percent covers from
twenty hertz to one thousand hertz and
the remaining ninety percent of the
sliders range covers
one thousand and one hertz to twenty
thousand hertz
and since i don't wanna be doing any
skewing right now i'm gonna leave this
set to one all right and then
the last thing is that um the default
value for this parameter now this
is the low cut parameter so we will give
it a default value of
20 hertz because that's the bottom of
the hearing range and we don't want to
hear this parameter do anything
unless we actually move it all right so
that takes care of the low-cut parameter
let me hide this
plug-in processor and just show the
plug-in plug-in thing so you can see the
full name of this guy right here
all right we've got our name we've got
our parameter name and we've got our
normalizable range right here
and this is our default value we are
going to do the same thing with the high
cut frequency
the only difference will be that we will
set the default value to 20
000 hertz because it's at the top of the
human hearing range and we don't want to
hear this parameter do anything
unless we decide to change the value so
i'm just going to copy this
i'm going to change the name to high cut
high cut and then this needs to be 20
000. now let's do the same thing for the
peak
frequency we will use the same range of
20 hertz to 20 000 hertz
um the same step size of one and the
same skew value of one the only
difference is we will set the center
frequency to a default of 750 hertz
and let's change the name to peak
for the peak gain we will be expressing
this parameter in decibels
and a good range of values to use here
is negative 24 to
positive 24. a step size of 0.5 means
that when we drag the slider
back and forth it will represent a
change of half of a decibel
and we want this slider to behave in a
linear fashion so we will use a skew of
one
and we don't want this to by default add
any sort of gain
or cut so we're going to use a default
value of zero so i'm going to copy this
we're going to change the name to peak
gain the
range is going to be negative 24.f
with a max of 24.f uh our step size
0.5 f our skew
of 1 and our default value of
f 0.0f that's our gain
next the peak band's quality control
the quality controls how tight or how
wide the peak band is
this is kind of an abstract number and
it doesn't have any units
you can have a pretty narrow q which is
reflected by having a high q value
or you can have a very wide q which is
reflected by having a very low
q value so let's give ourselves a low
value of
0.1 and a high value of 10.
though i'm going to copy this let's copy
this parameter
change this to quality change that's
quality
so we will um yeah so we're going to
give it a low value of 0.1 and a high
value of
10. i'm going to use a step size of 0.05
which means when we drag the slider
it's going to go 0.1 0.15 0.2
these can be pretty granular sizes which
means we can have a lot of control which
is good
and always we want a linear response so
we will set the skew on this
to one and on top of it we want to use a
generic default value
of one for the queue one dot
f all right for the low cut and high cut
filters
i want to have the ability to change the
steepness of the filter cut
so i will give myself some four
different options
okay our cut filters are normally
expressed in
uh decibels per octaves or their
responses are
normally expressed in decibels per
octave sorry
the way the math behind the filter
equations works ends up expressing these
choices in multiples of 6 or 12.
so that means we can have choices like
12 decibels per octave
24 36 so for this project we're going to
stick with four choices
12 24 36 48.
so because we are using specific choices
and not a range of values like with
these sliders
this means we get to use the audio
parameter choice
object so i'll show you what that's like
uh
audio parameter choice so that's this
thing right here
this thing uh it needs a string array
that represents the choices
and because both the low cut and high
cut will use the same set of choices
i only need to create this string array
once so we're going to do that
first let me get rid of this line let me
scroll
up okay so let's make our string array
and now we're gonna do four choices and
now we're going to construct uh
something that says 12 db
per oct or 24 and we can do that like
this
all right that should make a lot of
sense default value is zero
so we've got i'm sorry i's first value
is zero so we've got 12 plus zero then
12 plus 12
12 plus 24 12 plus 36 that gives us 12
24
36 48 and then we're just sticking uh db
per octave on the end of that string all
right now we just need to create the
audio parameter choice
and give it the string array of choices
and use the default value of 0
meaning the filter will have a default
slope of
12 db per octave let's create that now
this is going to be called
low cut slope
choice is going to be our string array
and our default index will be zero
all right and we just need to duplicate
this line for the high cut as well
all right now we have got our parameters
set up in our parameter layout so we
can just return it and pass it to the
audio processor tree value state
constructor which we have already done
we already did that right here all right
now if we run the app as it is right now
we are not going to see anything other
than that hello world
and that's because we haven't added
anything to our gui but
if i go up to the create editor function
we can use the generic
audio processor editor to see what our
parameters look like
so let's do that we're going to comment
that line out we're going to write
return
new generic
audio processor editor and it's going to
be
uh this okay so if we run it and take a
look
first of all make sure you are in
standalone mode
if we run it we are going to see
some good stuff okay if we look at our
combo boxes we can see that our slope
controls
show up this way there's our 12 24 36
and 48
peak control default value of one we can
see it goes you know zero point one
one five two five all the way up to ten
and then for our gain we've got twenty
four
we can see that it's stepping by um half
of a decibel every time
okay so next we will work on the signal
processing side of things
that's the next step to make all these
parameters actually do something
all right we've got some parameters set
up now this would be a good time to make
a commit and um
you know commit what we've done so that
way if
what we do in the next step gets messed
up we can always revert back to here and
try again so added parameters
we can see what we did we created the
audio processor value state
created the parameter layout then we
added our parameters and created the
made it give us the generic audio
processor editor
whenever we go to look at stuff and then
we also changed
the language to c plus 17
and did an export for in my case os x in
your case it's probably for
perhaps it's osx or windows um anyway
we'll add those things stage those and
make commit
all right so the next thing we're gonna
do is add uh some dsp
now before we do that before we actually
start writing dsp code we need to add
the dsp
module so go to producer click on the
modules thing right here
then click the plus button and you're
going to add a module
global juice global juice paths
and go to juice dsp all right once that
is in there
then we can click on this guy
and now we have access to all of the uh
the juice
dsp modules okay
i'm going to switch back to the single
view for right now so let me hide this
and then go back to pluginprocessor.h
back to my script if you have never
written any audio
software before or used any type of
audio software then you might not be
familiar with the concept of audio
channels
and stereo versus mono audio
so stereo means there's two channels
mono means there's only one
now each of the signal processing
classes in the dsp namespace
is set up to process mono audio
unless it's declared as stereo in the
documentation
so what that means is that it's only
going to process a single channel of
audio
and since this plugin is going to be
processing stereo audio
we need to duplicate all of the stuff we
are going to use
and the dsp namespace uses a lot
of template meta programming and nested
namespaces so let's help ourselves out
let's create some type aliases to
eliminate a lot of those namespace and
template definitions
first thing we're going to create is a
filter alias we're going to be
processing floats and not doubles in
this project
that's our first alias now i said before
how we can
set the slope of our cut filters to be
multiples of 12.
each of the filter types on in the iir
filter class has a response of 12 db per
octave when it is configured as a low
pass or high pass filter
so if we want to have a chain with a
response of 48 decibels per octave
we are going to need four of those
filters now a
central concept of the dsp namespace in
the juice framework is to define a chain
and then pass in a processing context
that's an important term
pass in a processing context which will
run through each element of the chain
automatically
so we can put four of these filters
in a processor chain which will allow us
to pass it a single context
and have it process all of the audio
automatically so let's do that
using cut filter equals so third chain
and then this is where we do one filter
two filter
three filter four filter as
i mentioned earlier if you configure the
filter as low pass or high pass
it will have a 12 db per octave slope
we can also configure that filter to
work as a peak filter or
shelf or notch or band pass or all pass
there's a couple other types
this means we can use one of these
filters to represent the
parametric filter so now that we have
the peak filter and the cut filters
represented as aliases
we can define a chain to represent the
whole
mono signal path so we'll do that using
mono chain equals juice dsp
processor chain and we will do a
cut filter then a normal filter and then
a cut filter
now we need two instances of this mono
chain if we want to do
stereo processing and
to have access to the filter instances
in order to adjust their cutoff
gain quality or slope so let's declare
that now
mono chain we got the left channel
and the right channel cool
now before we can use our um our filter
chains we need to prepare them
so let's go over to our prepare to play
and do that we must prepare our filters
before we use them
and we do this by passing a process spec
object
to the chains which will then pass it to
each link
in the chain so let's declare one of
those
and it needs to know the maximum number
of samples that it will
process at one time it needs to know the
number of channels
mono chains can only handle one channel
of audio
and it needs to know the sample rate now
we can pass it to each chain and they
will be
prepared and ready for processing
and let's just make sure everything's
cool and build it
build succeeded okay step number three
this requires us to jump down to our
process block
now the processor chain requires a
processing context to be passed
to it in order to run the audio through
the links in the chain
in order to make a processing context we
need to supply it with an
audio block instance now the process
block function
is called by the host and it is given a
buffer which can have
any number of channels so we need to
extract the left channel and the right
channel
from this buffer and the left and right
channels are typically
channels 0 and 1 respectively so the
first thing we have to do is create an
audio block
which wraps this buffer so let's do that
first we're going to get rid of this
stuff
right here and this is a block and it is
initialized with our buffer
now we can use the helper function in
the audio block class to extract
individual channels from the buffer
which will then be wrapped inside more
audio blocks so we can do
auto left block equals block dot
get single channel block we want channel
zero
do the same thing for the right channel
now that we have audio blocks
representing each individual channel we
can create processing contexts that wrap
each individual
audio block for the channels
process context replacing it's a float
we're going to call it the
left context
it's going to be initialized with the
left block
make another one all right
so we have our block representing an
individual channel we have a context
that kind of provides a wrapper around
that block that the
chain can use now we can pass these
contexts
to our mono filter chains left chain dot
process
and we want the left context and then
right chain dot process
right context now if we run it
it will work but we will not hear our
filters do anything because we have not
set up their coefficients
so this is going to be a good time to
set up the audio plugin host so we can
feed some
actual audio through our plugin and show
that the filters
are not doing anything but until then we
can actually just run this and you'll
see that it's not going to do anything
cool so we can drag all this stuff
there's no audio running through it so
we're not going to hear it do anything
okay let's get set up with audio plugin
host
this is uh this comes with juice
navigate to your juice
folder and then go to extras and now go
to audio plug and host
and now open the you can open the juicer
file if you want
i'll do that now i've got this here it's
just like the other thing where we have
all our source and our modules and
whatnot
so all we're going to do is just save
and open in ide
wait for this to open and now we just
need
to build it all right build succeeded
so we are done with um this project now
that was very easy okay what we have to
do now
is run it outside of our project
so go to the builds folder go to your
particular operating system i'm going to
go to mac os
go to build debug and now run it
all right it's going to want access to
whatever device you have
what we have to do now is scan our
system for the plugin
i haven't built it yet i've only built
the standalone version so i'm going to
change this
to all and i'm going to build it now
and what it's going to do is it's going
to create a vst3 it's going to create an
audio unit
and it's going to copy them to the
relevant locations on the computer
now i can go back to audio plug and host
and now i can go to the options menu and
edit the list of available plugins
and now under these options button here
this is where you're going to scan for
both
if you're on mac audio unit and vst3 so
we'll do vst3 first
it's going to find our simple eq because
we built it that way and then
for audio unit do the same thing my case
i have a bunch of uad stuff
so it's going to find all of that okay
so now that we have all of our audio
units that are built into the computer
and our vst3 close this available
plugins
list window now we can right click
right here go to the uh your company
unless you put something else in
and pick um vst3 for right now
here's our plugin so those good times
now we want to run some audio through it
so what we want to do is right click
here um on os
x you're going to go to the apple menu
you're going to go to the au
audio file player now this little plugin
lets us load files and play them
yeah we can load sound files and then
play them so we're gonna wire this
up connected to our audio output
and then be able to
hear audio running through our plugin so
just drag
like this and drag that to our audio
output
and um the other thing to do is you need
to make sure that under your um
options go to your audio device settings
and this is where you're going to
configure your audio on what you have
now i'm going to set this up with an
audio file that i have
feel free to set it up with your own i'm
just pulling something that i got from
youtube's free audio library so that way
this video doesn't cause any sort of
copyright issues or anything set it up
with whatever you have
and then um i'm also gonna configure it
so that it plays
through um so that the audio that i play
shows up in the video
instead of just going out of the audio
output all right so standby for that
okay i've got my au audio file player
set up
with a file that is not going to trigger
a copyright flag with
youtube i've got it wired up to this
simple eq that we've been working on
and it's connected to the audio output
so if i push play
i'm going to hear it through the
speakers and you guys are going to hear
through this video so check it out
[Applause]
all right cool so uh obviously this
stuff is not gonna do anything if i
adjust that
all right so that's the next thing we
are going to work on we need to
set this as what opens by default when
we run our application so we will
do that next a good thing to do once you
get this set up is
save the setting save the filter graph
setting i'm going to save it with
my project that's a good place to put it
programming put it right here and just
call it simple eq photograph
okay so now i can save that now i can
quit this and now i can configure
the audio um configure my project to run
audio plug and host when ever i run the
project so i'm going to do that with a
vst3
go here for os x you're going to go here
you're going to go to edits the scheme
and you're going to configure the
executable
so do other
and then just search for audio plugin
host
and there it is choose close
and now if we run it it's going to run
audio plug and host
and it should load our saved file
there it is okay so now we can um
now what we can do is actually debug our
stuff so if we add a break point right
here
um it's gonna pause execution right on
that which is cool
so now we can actually debug our code
and whatnot while it's running in there
okay so we are done with audio plug and
host for right now
okay we are going to connect some
parameters to our
filters but before we do that let's make
a commit and just you know jot down what
we did
so we went through this and we
initialized our chains
and we got our chains up and running
basically you could say we
added our dsp added dsp
right so here's where we created our
chains
here is where we initialized our chains
here is where we
started running audio through our chains
and then
this is where we did this is where we
set up our
filter graph and then here is where we
added the dsp module
okay with that out of the way now we can
start configuring our filter chain so go
to the plugin processor dot
h and we're going to go up to the top
now let's start by extracting our
parameters from the audio processor
value tree state
and a data structure representing all of
the parameter values
will keep our code nice and readable so
let's do that first
and now next let's write a helper
function that will give us all of these
parameter values in our little data
struct all right let's go to our cpp
file
now i'm going to implement this near
where i created the parameter layout so
it's easy to see the names
so i'm going to put that right above
this we'll just add this here
chain settings
okay now there are two ways to get
parameter values
from the ap vts the first way is to call
get parameter and then get value like
this
vts get parameter
some parameter name like low cut freak
and then get value but the problem with
that approach
is that we are given a normalized value
all of the functions that produce
coefficients for our filter expect
real-world values not normalized values
so we're not going to use this one what
we can use is a different function
we can use apvts.getraw parameter value
now this function returns the parameter
in units that we
care about units based on the ranges
that we set up when we defined the
parameters
so for instance for the low cut
frequency it's going to return a unit
that's within this range instead of a
normalized value between these two
values
so let's initialize all of our data
structures
all of the properties in our data
structure using this function
these raw parameter values are atomic
which is handy when we are interacting
with the gui later
i'm not going to talk about any of the
thread safety issues that come along
with audio development
in this particular course but you can
learn all about that stuff
in my course which teaches how to build
the full channel equalizer
and in several talks on youtube from the
audio developer conference
so let's go through these and start
setting up our settings
okay there's all the parameters getting
them all low cut free high cut freak
peak freak peak gain
making sure we're using all the names
that we used here
let's go up to our prepare to play
function
all right we're going to do this after
we've prepared our chain now that we
have our settings we can
start producing coefficients using the
statter static helper functions
that are part of the iir coefficients
class
so we can do this auto chain
now we can do auto peak efficience
equals make peak filter
now we need the sample rate
and our center frequency which is going
to be chain
settings oops chain settings
dot peak freak chain settings
dot q quality and then
for the gain parameter this particular
parameter expects a value in gain units
not decibels so we must convert our
decibel value to gain thankfully there
is a handy helper function to do just
that
so that's juice decibels class and then
this function and we feed it
change settings dot peak gain in
decibels
all right let's put all that stuff on
its own line so it's easy to look at
now that we have our coefficients for
the peak filter we can set our filters
coefficients accordingly
now you can access links in the
processor chain via
a get function like this left chain dot
get
and it's templated this function wants
an
index to a particular element in the
chain
via its template argument so let's help
ourselves out
and define an enum that represents each
link's position in the chain and use it
here all right so we're just going to
leave that
the way it is let's go back to our
header file
we'll go down here to where our chain is
and let's define
and enum here enum chain positions
and we're going to have low cut peak
and high cut and this goes along with
what we have here we have a low cut
the peak band and then the cut area
right here we could change this to
parametric if we wanted
okay now that we have that let's go back
to our cpp file go back to prepare to
play
all right let's use it to access our
peak filter link and assign some
coefficients
so we're going to go chain positions
peak like that all right that's how we
get that particular filter link
all right now the coefficients object
this thing right here
is basically a reference counted wrapper
around an array that is allocated on the
heap
now we want to copy its values over so
we need to de-reference it
and don't ask me why the juice people
decided to design their coefficients
object this way
allocating on the heap in an audio
callback is bad
but we're going to ignore that design
flaw for right now and just keep moving
forward
alright so we are going to access the
coefficients
and we're going to assign it across peak
coefficients like that
and now we just need to de-reference
them and then we'll do the same thing
with the right chain
okay at this point our peak filter has
been set up and will make
audible changes to the audio running
through it if the gain parameter is not
zero however any changes we make to
these sliders
will not cause audible changes because
we are not updating the filter with new
with new coefficients
whenever the slider changes so let's do
that next
in our process block so let's go on to
our processing process block
and we need to do this before we run
audio through it
always update your parameters before you
process audio through them
okay so let's just copy the code we
created and prepare to play
right where we created our coefficients
we can refactor this later let's just
copy that for now
go to process block put this right after
this buffer
clear stuff happens after that put it
right here
okay again we can refactor this later
even though it's identical
the only thing you need to change is
this guy let's fix this so we can just
call
get sample rate and now if we run it and
adjust the gain q and frequency
sliders we will hear some audible
changes
okay i have run it and let's see what it
gets see what it gets us okay we're just
going to mess around with the peak
frequency stuff
[Music]
okay all right it did something
cool so you might notice that the filter
slider is kind of
wonky that's because our ears hear
frequencies
sorry that's because of how our ears
hear versus how
frequencies work if the sound goes up
one octave
the frequency doubles so this is an
instance of where we want to change the
skew parameter of our frequency slider
let's play around with some different
values until we find something we like
so we go down to where our parameters
are created
um let's see which parameter was the
skew parameter
i think it was that's step size yeah
that's step size so it's the last
parameter so i'm gonna just try 0.5
for the um let's see i'm messing with
the peak frequency so we'll do that one
first
go like that let's rerun this stop
i'm going to change it to 0.5 basically
what it's going to do is adjust how the
filter responds
when i drag the slider okay
all right now this is going to be more
noticeable when you are
messing with um actual like an actual
graphical slider
that you're designing versus these um
sliders here
so either way i'm gonna keep messing
with this and we'll see what value i end
up arriving on
so something you might notice here is
like um the range is 20 to 20 000.
um if the slider's in the middle you
would think that a value of 0.5 would
result in
10 000 hertz but we don't actually see
that until we're way over here
this is what i was saying before about
the skew thing so i can i can
based on this skew that i have right
here of 0.25
the um from 20 hertz to 10 000 hertz is
spread out across this range and then 10
000 to 20 000
fits here in this little range right
here so that's
what the skew parameter lets us deal
with
okay so something that i'm noticing when
setting that skew
really far down like 0.15 or whatever
is i hit the bottom of the range here
and it doesn't go up to the next
frequency
until right there so that's a big chunk
of the slider that's not
usable based on this skew valid
sku value of 0.15 so i'm going to put
this back to 0.25 and i'm going to use
that for
every other frequency parameter okay
so with that said we you know added a
little bit of code so
let's go ahead and make a commit this is
going to be
um let's see we implemented
all right sorry we connected the peak
filter params to the filter
all right let's go ahead and commit that
stuff all right on to the next step
okay we are going to get the low cut
filters connected to the
low cut parameters now if you remember
if we jump back over here the cut
filters were built with
their own processor chain instance
and that instance has four
filters within it as i said before each
of these
filters has a 12 db per octave response
if it is configured as a
low pass or high pass filter we are
going to use a helper function from the
juice framework that allows us to define
iir
filters with custom orders and we've
been describing the slope
in terms of decibels per octave but the
slope of
cut filters is also known as its order
okay also a low cut filter is also
called a high pass filter and
likewise a high cut filter is also
called a low pass
filter so let's go take a look at the
helper function we're going to use let's
jump over to
plugin processor go to the end of
prepare to play and we're going to
we're just going to call it so we can
jump to the definition of it
all right just give us some default
parameters it is the design
iir high pass high order butterworth
method
okay so just jump to the definition of
that
that's going to take us to the
declaration but we want the actual
implementation of this
okay if we take a quick look at the
implementation
for example this little loop right here
we'll do this loop because we're going
to do even numbered orders
okay right here
if we look at the implementation you
will see that it creates one
iir filter coefficient object for every
two orders so if the order is two
we are only going to get one of these
that's what i mean how like
uh this gives us a 12 db per octave cut
if it's
four if our order is four we are going
to get two sets of coefficients if our
order is six we will get three et cetera
et cetera
so what we need to do is produce the
required number of coefficient
objects that are needed based on what
our slope
parameter is set to now remember the
this parameter had four choices it was
12
24 36 48 let me jump over to plugin
processor and go down to where
we created our parameters i was down
here
we had four choices total
all right so the first choice is at
index zero
if our choice is 12 db per octave
which is index zero we want to get back
one coefficient object
and to do that that means we need to
supply
an order of two okay if our choice is 24
like if we're doing i equals one
we need to supply an order of four in
order to get
two coefficients back okay ergo
our possible orders are then
as in i'm talking about this parameter
right here this parameter
our possible orders are 2 4
6 and 8 okay so we need to add 1 to our
slope choice
and then multiply that by two
to get the order to use when calling
this helper function
okay once we have done that we can get
our array of coefficients from this
helper function
okay i'm going to say that one more time
our possible orders are 2 4 6
8. so remember our slope choices are 0 1
2
3 so what we have to do is add 1
to our slope choice and multiply that
sum by
2 in order to get the correct order to
pass
to this function okay let's do that now
go to plugin processor
go back up to the prepare to play
function
and we're going to just get rid of this
line we're going to do
auto cut coefficients equals and now
we're going to call that
all right our frequency is going to be
the chain settings
low cut frequency sample rate sample
rate
and our order is going to be remember
we're going to do our
chain settings our slope for the low cut
we're going to add 1 to it we're going
to multiply that value
by 2. 2 times that
all right let's put these all in their
their own line so it's easy to look at
okay chain settings remember this is a
value between
zero one two and three so we're gonna
add one to that that's gonna give us one
two three four and then we're gonna
double it which is gonna give us two
four six eight
okay now we need to start
let's start by initializing the left
chain first
all right so let's get the low cut
filter chain
so we'll just do auto left low cut
we're gonna get it chain position whoops
all right now first we are going to
bypass
all of the links in the chain
all right remember there are four
positions so we need to bypass all four
right now it would be ideal to be able
to switch
based on the slope setting so to make
the code more readable let's define
another enum that represents our slope
setting
since enums decay to integers which is
what our choice parameter is expressed
in
let's go to the top of our plugin
processor.h
we're going to define an enum up here so
i want to have the
slope amount in the enums member names
and since we can't
use numbers to begin identifiers in c
plus i'm going to put slope before that
so we will do
enum slope
and i will do slope
12.
all right now let's um let's adjust what
the filter chain slopes are specified as
let's change this guy right here so
instead of it being low cut slope
expressed with an integer let's express
it with a slope
all right we'll do the same thing for
the high cut okay now if we try to
compile
we will get an error
let's fix this error next all right what
we have to do is
change the data type right here to uh
we're just going to cast this to that
slope type right here
do the same thing for this line and try
building it again
cool problem solved all right
now we have our enum which gives us you
know specific types that we can switch
on
let's go back to our prepare to play
function
oops all right that's down here now we
can do a switch statement so
switch and we want to do uh chain
settings low cut slope
i'm too lazy to type the switch types so
i'm going to let the autocomplete do it
all right add missing switch cases yes
okay now we just need to fill them in if
our order is 2
meaning a 12 db per octave slope
the helper function will return an array
with one
coefficient object only so we will
assign those coefficients to the
first filter in the cut filter chain and
also stop
bypassing that filter chain so we will
do
um let's see left low cut dot get
first filter in that chain we want the
coefficients and we're going to assign
it to
our cut coefficients the first element
now remember we have to dereference and
then
we are going to stop bypassing
this particular chain all right
now for the next choice we will do the
same thing that we did when the slope
was 12
however the helper function will return
an array with two
coefficient objects so we will find we
will assign
to the first two links in the filter
chain and stop bypassing them
all right i'm just going to copy this
and then copy it again
and change these to one all right we're
going to repeat for the third
and fourth option when the slope is 36
and when the slope is 48.
all right now that's obviously not you
know optimized there's a lot of
repetition in the code going on we'll
deal with that later
okay all we have to do now is repeat
this for the right chain
and our slider and combo box for the low
cut filter
will configure the filter properly
so we are going to get the right chain
and let's just copy all of this
and replace all of the left low cut with
right low cut
okay all right as i said there is a lot
of repetition here
and it could do with some refactoring
but let's not do that just yet okay
first let's copy this chunk of code to
our process block just like we did with
the peak filter
and we should be able to run it and test
the sliders in the combo box and hear
it adjusting the low cut filter all
right so just grab all of this
grab cut coefficients like that
jump to process block we're going to put
this after our peak coefficient stuff
right like that okay the only difference
is uh
sample rate we need to call get sample
rate again
all right let's run it
okay we should be able to adjust the low
cut frequency as well as the low cut
slope and here it make a difference
all right let's adjust the slope
[Music]
i'm going to put it around 2500 put it
around 4 000.
we can definitely hear there's more
bottom end when we use us
a more gentle slope versus a steeper
slope
all right i'm happy with that
okay let's uh make a commit since we did
some good work right there
we added the uh let's see we connected
the
low cut parameters to the filter
we made our enum we adjusted our chain
settings how they are defined
and we added our coefficients and we got
them working with our
um working with the filter and then we
also updated how we pulled them from the
uh
from the process block or from the apvts
all right cool on to the next thing we
will refactor
what we are doing
okay let's start the refactor with
cleaning up the stuff that configures
the peak filter
let's just do a uh a function here at
the bottom
all right we're going to update the peak
filter with the change settings
i'm going to implement this beneath
where i am
getting the chain settings
now i'm going to just copy the
implementation from the process block
paste it here replace it in the process
block and then do the same thing in
prepare to play
i'm just gonna copy this stuff paste it
here
and now i'm gonna call this i'm gonna do
the same thing in prepare to play
very easy now let's add a helper
function since we will be updating lots
of coefficients like we are updating
them
here we're updating them here here
here here okay so let's go back to our
header file
and let's do that here now i'm not sure
of the exact type that the dsp iir
filter class uses for its coefficients
if we take a look over here it uses this
thing which is an alias to whatever this
is
but we can make an alias to that alias
very easily
and now it's very easy to declare this
helper function that will update those
coefficients
now it doesn't use any member variables
so it could be a free function or it
could be a static member variable
a static member function so i'm going to
go with static for this
particular instance because i'm already
right here i don't want to have to
scroll up to make a free function
all right and let's go implement that
below where we implemented our
update peak code okay remember they're
um reference counted objects allocated
on the heap so we need to de-reference
them to get the underlying object
now we can use it here
the old ones are going to be this thing
the replacements are going to be this
thing
we'll do the same thing for the right
chain
okay let's run this and then move the
sliders make sure it works and if it's
cool then we'll delete this old code
and then do the low cut filter next
okay so we're just going to mess with
the peak filter
all right it's making changes make it
tight
give it a little sleepy heat
cool all right let's clean this up and
then commit our changes
let's build just to make sure that what
we deleted is cool
all right let's make a commit all right
here we go commit that stage all this
stuff
boom okay we can refactor how the low
cut filter gets configured next and then
we can use that same code to configure
the high cut filter
let's refactor how the low cut filter is
updated
so we'll be able to use this later for
the high cut filter
now i'm not sure what type names to use
for the parameters here
so i'm going to use a templated function
so let's go to our header file
and put this down here template type
name chain type and then
void update cut filter now a trick one
refactoring something like this is to
use the same names you were using in the
unrefactored code
so i'm going to use uh if we go take a
look at our plugin processor
i'm going to use the same names here
where i've got cut coefficients
and then left low cut and then
low cut slope i'm going to use those
same names for right now
okay so we're going to do a chain type
of
left low cut i'm going to use a
coefficients type of
cut coefficients and then i've got my
chain settings const chain settings
chain settings all right so let's copy
over the stuff
from process block first and call it in
process block
and then comment and comment out the old
stuff and we will fix any errors along
the way so let's go to our
plug-in processor we're going to grab
this cut coefficient stuff
and then all of this code right here
and now let's comment it out and
call our function all right we want to
call it with our
uh left low cut let me call this
after this point so i still need this
thing
all right so let's see and i still need
my cut coefficients too
okay cut filter we're going to call it
with left low cut we're going to call it
with cut coefficients
and our chain settings let's uh give
that a quick build just to make sure
that that works as expected all right we
have some
errors going on here oh yes okay so
we're not passing this and we're not
passing that
so comment that out and that should be
good to go all right
so we need to add some template keywords
right here template
and that also needs to go here
in front of these since these are
template functions we have to express
we have to explicitly declare that they
are
templated like this it's one of the more
obscure
uh c plus plus rules all right
okay cool build succeeded all right the
left cut filter is configured so we can
tackle the right cut filter
with our helper function now so we just
do this same thing
comment out all of this code call our
helper function
and use the right low cut we'll do a
quick build just to make sure
build succeeded all right cool now we
aren't using the entire
chain settings object we're only using
the slope
so let's go back and change our switch
statement okay we're going to get rid of
this
and we're going to change our parameter
so we're going to get rid of this we're
going to change this to be
const uh slope low cut
slope and now we can change this line to
be switch
low cut slope let's build it we should
get some errors
because we need to change what we're
calling it with this is where we need to
do
low cut slope and then on the next one
as well all right and if we build it we
should get no errors
okay cool no errors so let's revise
prepare to play now
let's go up here to prepare to play and
we need our coefficients our left
low cut as well as our right low cut so
let's get rid of
uh this code and this code
and now let's call uh we'll get rid of
that code too
and now we can call our code we can call
our
function we'll start with the left low
cut filter chain
update cut filter with the left low cut
chain
and our cut coefficients and our left
low cut uh this is where we need our
chain settings
dot um low cut slope and then do the
same thing for the high cut or for the
right
low cut our slider and combo box
for the low cut filter should configure
the
uh dsp filter properly all right let's
test out our refactor
and if it's cool we will delete all this
code and um
do commit okay let's run it and see what
we get
okay so we are going to mess with the
low cut now and the slope
[Music]
that's working
all right i am very happy with that
let's clean this up and make a commit
all right let's clean up our header file
okay let's build it just to make sure
all right looking good updated
or refactored low cut
configuration load code filter
configuration all right this is where we
added our helper function
this is where we deleted our helper our
old code
and now call the updated stuff
now this is obviously very verbose so
let's clean this up
we're going to use a special trick just
comment all of this out
if we reverse the switch order we can
leverage
case path uh we can leverage case
pass-through to eliminate a ton of code
duplication here
so i'm going to do that first all right
we're just going to put the cases in the
opposite order case slope
okay the way this works is like if it's
the 48th
if it's if our slope is 48 we wanted to
do this one
and then we also wanted to do all of
these so we can just make it
instead of making it break out of the
switch we can just do okay if it's 48
do this do that one here and then and
then do also do the one that is required
for 36.
we can also write a templated helper
function to eliminate even more
duplicated code
because we're doing this thing and yeah
all right so let's write that next right
above this guy
all right so we're going to do template
we'll add these parameters next uh
void update so we're gonna need our
chain
we're gonna need the coefficients
and then um so we're gonna need our
chain type and our coefficients
and then if you notice all of these make
use of this
get or set bypass and use as a parameter
here
so we are going to make this be the
first parameter because
if you didn't notice when we called this
function we didn't have to provide any
of these template arguments
so the compiler deduced what to put here
automatically so if we
leave these as the later template
arguments the compiler can deduce them
for us and we only need to provide uh
the um
that index so we're gonna do that int
index okay now we can just do that
update coefficients function
update coefficients and our old one is
going to be chain
dot this thing right here template get
dot coefficients
all right and our coefficient
replacement type is going to be the
coefficients uh cut coefficients is that
the name i'm using there i'm going to
change that name
to just coefficients
and the index that we use if you notice
it's always when it's get zero
we always use the zero with cut
coefficient index when it's one we use
the index one okay so whatever we put
here
our index is the same thing we're going
to use here
index all right how convenient is that
and then
we need to set the bypass state to false
so we can call that
chain dot template set bypassed
index false
cool all right now we just need to call
it
all right so remember if we're doing the
48
degree slope we want to call this
all right and this is being replaced by
that
update function
this is where we want index three and
our chain type
is left low cut and our coefficient type
is the cut
coefficient all right let me spell that
right
all right that gets rid of these lines
all right we do the same thing three two
one zero
three two one
zero zero okay
let's test that out make sure that works
if it does then we can clean this
up all right so we're gonna run it we're
gonna adjust this and adjust this
[Music]
all right that's filtering put this on
48
this to 5 000
and we'll change the slope and we hear
more bottom end material
not much more but
all right cool awesome
let's make a commit of that after we
clean it up
all right cool is there anything in here
that needs cleaning up
i don't think there is prepare to play
nope all right
let's make a commit of that so
refactored
chain update refactored
update cut filter code very cool
got some more advanced c plus plus stuff
going on with that
all right now we can uh connect the high
cut parameters
to the um to the filters all right so
let's go over to our plug-in
processor.cpp and go up to the um
go to the prepare to play function first
of all
now we need to um let's see
go back to my notes here uh we need to
rename our
coefficients before we dig into high cut
filter configuration so let's change
this to be low cut con
low cut coefficients
all right now that we've done that now
we can configure the high cut chain
we're going to follow the same pattern
uh we're going to call the helper
function to get coefficients and then
we're going to call the helper function
to update the filters with those
coefficients okay
so we're going to do auto high cut
coefficient
equals juice
okay we want the design low pass high
order butterworth method
all right same thing it's going to be
the chain settings
dot the high cut frequency same sample
rate
and then our order is going to be this
same
expression
but it's going to be the high cut slope
okay now we can get our left chain in
right chain
left high cut high cut
do left chain and right chain
okay and now we can just call this uh
call this guy call it with left high cut
and the uh high cut slope
and then do it again for the right side
and then we need to use our high cut
coefficients
and then we will do the same thing uh we
can obviously refactor this later
we can do the same thing in our process
block now
process block let's just put this at the
end of our update
filter code here and then oh we need our
get sample rate
and now uh now this is in place we can
uh
run it and test it
all right so we're going to be testing
the high cut frequency and the high cut
[Music]
slope
all right so i'm going to set this
around 2500 hertz
now if i change the slope i should hear
less and less high frequency
perfect all right cool
let's do a um don't repeat yourself
refactor
and um that'll wrap it up for the dsp
side of things
that was easier than probably you
thought
so the first thing we are going to do is
go to our plugin processor dot h
down here let's make a function that's
going to update all the filters
now we need a pair of functions one for
the low cut and one for the high cut and
this will be
these will be called by the uh by this
update filters function
okay so
all right takes care of those let's go
over to our plugin processor dot cpp
i'm going to jump to after the updates
coefficient
function update coefficients function
i'm going to copy the relevant code
from processblock to the implementation
for the uh
update low cut filter
let me grab that from processblock
all right let's just copy that
paste that here make sure we're getting
the coefficients and then updating both
chains
we're going to do the same thing for the
high cut void
simple
let's go grab that code from the process
block
i cut coefficients update cut filter
all right now we need to implement our
update filter function
so i'm going to do that below this
now i just need to get the chain
settings auto
change settings equals get chain
settings
now i can call update low cut filters
update peak filter
update high cut filter
now we just need to replace all of that
stuff in process block
with a call to that update filters
function
all right we don't need our chain
settings anymore we don't need any of
this
update filters okay let's do the
same thing in uh prepare to play
all right we lose all of this code which
is great
all right let's run it just to make sure
all right we're going to adjust all the
sliders and we should work
as expected
[Music]
there's our low cut
[Music]
all right low cuts working
is the high cut working get rid of some
more high end
okay high cuts working let's mess with
the peak
so
cool all right that works let's clean
this up
delete that code go to our process block
delete all this code all right let's see
if there's anything else that's
commented out
not just those guys just those guys okay
uh dry
refactored dsp config
dsp filter configuration
all right commit okay cool
so that wraps it up for the dsp side of
things
okay so that's awesome all right
the next stuff we get to work on is the
gui side of things we get to design a
custom
interface and knobs and get the response
curve showing up and the
fft analysis showing up in the
background as well
okay see you in the next one
okay before we start on the gui let's
implement
saving and loading of our plugins
parameter state
it's very easy to do because the plug-in
state is stored in the
apvts's member called state
let me show you what that looks like all
right so right down here there's a
public member variable
okay this is where all of the um
basically the generic values are stored
in this
okay so let's go back to our plugin
processor dot cpp
and we're going to go to the what's the
name of this function
get state information the state member
as i said was a
it's an instance of a juice value tree
and those serialize
to memory very easily so we can use a
memory output stream
to handle the busy work needed to write
the ap vts
state to the memory block that this
function has been given by the host
talking about this memory block right
here alright so we can just make a
memory output stream
take one that uh writes to a memory
block dest data
yes we want to append to the existing
content
let's call it mls for memory output
stream
now we just write it a p v t s dot
dot write to stream mos
that's it how simple is that likewise we
can do the reverse
we can restore our plug-in state from
memory using a value tree helper
function
the only thing we need to check for is
if the tree uh that was pulled from
memory
is valid before we copy it to our
plugins state
so let's use that function all right we
want this one read from data
we're gonna pass it data we're gonna
pass it size in bytes
okay once we know the tree is valid
then we can replace our plug-in state
and also update our filters with these
saved
parameter values so apbts.replacestate
with the new one and then update filters
how simple is that so now if we run this
in audio plug and host
we should be able to tweak the
parameters and then um
it will be restored oh this i changed
the folder name so i need to reload
where this is
okay so for example i'm going to change
this from 20
to whatever that number is okay save it
quit
we're going to reopen and it's no longer
20 it is on
4573 cool all right we can double click
to reset it back to the default value
our parameters are saved between loads
cool okay let's get back to using
our editor instead of the generic one so
we're gonna
uncomment this line or we're gonna
comment this line out and uncomment this
one
all right so now we are gonna be shown
an editor that has no gui
um it just says hello world okay so
we're back to this all right so we're
going to start adding
knobs and sliders and all that kind of
stuff okay so the first thing that i
want to do
we're going to switch over to
plugineditor.cpp
first thing i want to do is give
ourselves some more room so we're going
to make this
600 by 400. all right we're also going
to switch to the standalone
plugin instead of the host for right now
okay if we run this we're going to see
a bigger window cool all right
definitely better
now let's go to plugineditor.h now i
don't want to have to type this base
class initialization for every slider
that i'm going to make because they're
all going to be rotary sliders and
they're not going to have a text box so
i'm going to create a class that does
this
automatically in the constructor and
just use that for every slider in the
gui
i'm going to put that right here
we're inheriting from slider and then
we're going to set it so that it's using
the rotary horizontal vertical drag
style and then a no text box position
now we need to add some sliders so let's
add them
right here okay we're going to deal with
the slope controls later
for right now we're just going to show
the frequency and gain and quality
sliders okay
so custom rotary slider
and we want our peak freak slider
we want our peak gain slider
we want our peak quality slider
we want our low cut freak slider
we want our high cut freak slider
now when i have a bunch of components
that are going to be have that are going
to have the same thing done to them all
the time i like to add a
i like to add a function that's going to
give me all of them in a vector
so that way i can just iterate through
them easily so i'm going to do that next
all right now it's very easy to
implement let's go to plug-in editor
we'll put this after resized
and all we have to do is just return a
vector with um all of our components in
that's super easy to use we just need to
do it uh before
we call set size so we're gonna do that
right here for
auto comp get comps
and then we can do add and make visible
all right the next thing we need to do
is to position them all
now juice live constant is a very useful
tool for this
we're going to put these right here yeah
when it's time to dial in specific
positions i will use
juice live constant because it basically
lets me adjust positions of things
while the editor is visible which is
very handy but for right now what i'm
going to do is reserve the top third of
display
third of the display for showing the
frequency response
of the filter chain and then the bottom
two thirds is going to go
it's going to be dedicated to the
placement of all the sliders so i'm
going to do that
next
all right so the way this works is i've
got my bounding box for the component
i'm dedicating an area for the top
basically like i'm chopping off a
rectangle i'm
chopping off uh 33 of the height
that's going to get stored in this
response area now i'm going to put the
low cut stuff
on the left so i'm chopping out 33
of the bounding box in its current form
that's going to go to the left and then
the high cut area
so if you remember i've got basically
100 this is taking up 33 percent
and so this is rep this bounds right now
represents 66 percent
so i want to take half of that which
gives me another 33
that's going to be the right third of
the display now i just set my um
my low cut frequency slider and my high
cut frequency slider
to be in the left side and right side
and then
for my peak slider i'm going to set that
at the top of that center column it's
going to get the top third
same thing's going to happen here this
now
after this call has a height
of two-thirds of what it used to be so
we want
half of that to give us one-third for
the peak gain and then one third for the
quality
okay so if we run this we're going to
see knobs
or sliders or whatever we want to call
them okay cool
so here's our big old low cut slider
here's our high cut slider and then
here is our um peak frequency here's our
peak gain and then here's our peak
quality and you can see these guys are
uh they each share uh 33
of the um of their allotted space
all right next we're going to add these
slope sliders
all right let's go back to our header
file we're going to add these
over here they're just going to be
they're going to use the same custom
rotary thing these are going to be low
cut low cut slope
slider and then um high
cut slope slider and we got to add them
to our list of components
and then we need to position them so
let's put them after our low cut
frequency slider
we are going to make this uh let's see
this is going to be low cut area we're
going to
we're gonna cut we're gonna divide the
low cut uh side of things in half
and then we'll do the same thing uh
let's see this is where we're gonna do
low
cut slope slider not set bounds
low cut area and then for the high cut
we're gonna do the same thing we're
gonna do remove from top
make sure it's that guy and now we can
do
high cut slope slider dot set bounds
high cut area
all right so we are removing we're
basically removing from the top of this
low cut area
um a a rectangle that is half
of its original size and giving that to
the low cut
and then using what that leftover piece
goes this
to the low cut slope slider right
check it out we're going to run it
you'll see those two sliders have the
same size on either side all right
yeah these guys have the same size these
guys all have the same size
all right cool so though those are the
uh sliders they have now been positioned
on the screen
okay the next thing we need to do is um
connect them
to our um to our parameters so let's
make a commit
added sliders to
gui all right commit
all right let us connect the parameters
to these sliders now
let's go down to um our plugin editor.h
okay uh below where all of our sliders
are declared the apvts has an
attachment class which makes it very
easy to connect sliders to the audio
parameters
however the name is very long so let's
use a type name alias to help out with
the reason with the
readability here so using
and using ap vts equals that super long
class name
and now we can create an attachment
alias as well
right now we just need to declare one
attachment for every one of these
sliders
all right the next step is to initialize
them
properly so we go up to our constructor
and we have to initialize all of them
here so what we need to do is
write um they take three parameters so
let's see
um peak freak slider attachment
all right it needs the audio processor
value tree state to use we're gonna use
the audio
processor abvts the parameter id
peak freak and if we're not quite sure
about that we can go back over here
and double check so we got low cut free
ki-cut freak
peak freak peak gain peak quality low
cut slope high cut slope
so the good thing about this project is
there are not a lot of parameters
um which means we can kind of get away
with
typing them like this um if our project
had way more
parameters in it we would want to
standardize how
they are named um and use some kind of
lookup table
with std map or something so that way
um it's impossible to spell them wrong
here
that sort of thing we can yeah just use
the lookup table and some kind of enum
system to
index into the uh parameters okay
so let's connect this to the proper
slider peak freak
slider all right that's one so we need
to do this
for all of these guys here okay that was
this one we need to do it for all of
these
okay once we get to this point
uh all we have to do is just test it and
see that our sliders work as expected
and their value is preserved when
closing the gui
or closing and reopening the app so
let's do that
right now i'm just gonna do the
standalone version
okay uh we're just gonna adjust this guy
i'm gonna close it and reopen it
cool that's at the same spot let's do it
in um uh audio plug and host
all right let's run some audio through
it closing the gui
reopening the gui where it needs to be
save and click that and reopen it just
to double check
reopen our gui sure enough
all right that was at 12 o'clock and now
it's not it was at 0
db all right so that is working as
expected
cool so we have successfully connected
our
uh default sliders to their parameters
and they
save and load whenever we open and close
the gui cool
let's make a commit of that connected
sliders to parameters
all right that's where we added the
attachments here's where we resave
something in the filter graph
here is where we initialized all those
attachments
our next goal is to display the response
curve of the filter
so to do that we need to give the editor
its own instance of the mono chain
and to do that we need to make all of
the stuff that makes the mono chain
public so we will move all of those type
aliases
out of the audio processor and also make
the chain positions enum public
so head on over to public to a plugin
processor dot h
we're gonna grab all this stuff we're
gonna move it to the top
put it uh below your chain settings and
then grab that
edom chain positions copy this guy
and put that here oh now we're gonna
have some duplicate definitions so let's
get rid of this
and get rid of this and
clean it up head on over to
plugineditor.h
and we need to give ourselves an
instance of this we can put that right
here
mono chain mono chain
all right let's just give her a little
compile test
make sure it's cool all right cool build
succeeded
let's make a little commit of that gave
editor
its own mono chain stage stage
now we're going to start drawing the uh
response curve
all right head on over to
plugineditor.cpp
we're gonna go to the paint function and
that's this guy right here now the first
thing we're gonna do
is fill it with black so get rid of this
actually i'm gonna we're gonna use the
juice name space right here
using namespace juice
so now we don't have to type juice colon
colon everywhere
let's get rid of this colors
black all right we're gonna fill it with
a black
um black background all right let's get
rid of this stuff as well
first we need the area that we will draw
the response curve in
auto bounds equals get local bounds
and our response area was this thing so
let's copy that
and then our width is something that we
will also need auto w
equals response area dot get width
next we will need the individual chain
elements
and then we will call the function get
magnitude for frequency
for each filter in the chain so let's
get our
get our chain elements
so to use that function we are going to
need the sample rate we can get that
from the
audio processor to use that get
magnitude for frequency function
so this is where we can do audio
processor to get sample rate
and we are going to need a place to
store all of these magnitudes
which are returned from that function as
doubles
now we are computing one magnitude per
pixel so let's pre-allocate the space
that we need
now we just need to iterate through each
pixel and compute the magnitude at that
frequency
now magnitude is expressed as gain
units and gain units are multiplicative
unlike decibels which are additive so we
need a starting gain
of 1. now we just need to call the
magnitude function for a particular
pixel
mapped from pixel space to frequency
space
and we will use a special helper
function for that
called map to log base 10. we're mapping
the normalized pixel number to its
frequency within the human hearing range
that looks like this our value our
normalized value
oops let me be consistent with how i'm
doing my casting
and our minimum range is 20 and our max
range is 20
000. all right now we just need to call
the magnitude function with this
frequency
uh what's it called get magnitude for
frequency function
and multiply the results with our
magnitude right here
okay so we just need to check if a band
is bypassed
because if the band is bypassed we're
not going to do that multiplication
so if mono chain dot is bypassed
all right if it's bypassed ignore it all
right if it's not bypassed then we're
going to do mag
times equals and here's where we do the
peak band
coefficients and this is where we're
going to call that get magnitude for
frequency
all right our frequency is this thing
right here
and our sample rate is this thing we
just need to do the same thing for every
other filter in the low and high cut
chains
all right so i'm going to do that now
and the thing to remember is that the
low cut if you remember how it's defined
it is defined as a its own processor
chain so we need to get each individual
element of it versus getting it from the
mono chain
all right so i've got that for the low
cut so i'm just going to do that for all
four of the filters in the low cut
and then do the same thing for the high
cut
all right now we just need to convert
this magnitude into decibels and store
it
now that we've got our magnitudes we can
convert this
uh vector of magnitudes into a path
and we can build this path from the
vector of decibels and then draw it okay
so let's do the first thing let's build
our path
now we need to map our decibel value to
the response area
and a helper lambda will do the job we
could also use a free function but
i'm right here so i'm just going to do
it right here let me define some
maximum and minimum positions in the
window
i'm going to use jmap to map from my
source input which is a range of
negative 24 to plus 24.
and my output is where it's going to map
to the window position
now i came up with this negative 24 and
plus 24 because
the peak control can go from plus 24 to
negative 24. so i want my response curve
the window for it to have a range of
plus 24 to negative 24.
so that's where these figures come from
all right
so let's see output min output max
all right now we can start a new subpass
a new sub path
with the first magnitude start new sub
path we're going to start it at
our response area dot get x this is the
left
edge of the component and the first
value is going to be
map mags.front
so we're going to run the first value in
our magnitudes vector
through this map function and we're
mapping our decibels
to screen coordinates now we just need
to create
line twos for every other every other
magnitude
all right response curve line two and we
want to go to
response curve uh response area
get x plus i and then we want to do
map mags i
now let's give ourselves a nice
background border and then draw the path
g.draw rounded rectangle we're going to
draw that response area
it wants a float rectangle corner size
let's use a corner size of four
and a line thickness of one now we can
uh
let's use a white color all right g dot
set color
and now we can draw our path i'm gonna
do a path
stroke type of two this is gonna draw a
rounded rectangle with a line thickness
of one
one pixel wide this is gonna draw with a
line thickness of two pixels wide
all right let's run this and let's see
what we get
let's open our gui all right cool we
have a nice flat line inside a rounded
rectangle right at the middle
okay now why aren't we seeing anything
if we drag these sliders
this is because these sliders only
update the filter chain in the audio
processor
we also need to make them update the
filter chain in the editor because it's
a different chain
so let's do that next okay we need to do
that whenever the parameters change
all right oops i'm going to leave that
open so that when this
this opens automatically we get to see
our gui every time we run it
all right so we are going to set up the
filter chain in the editor
to follow the parameters next okay make
your way to the
plugin editor dot h now the easiest way
to respond to parameter changes is to
register as a listener to
all of them so let's do that
we're going to inherit from audio
processor parameter listener
now let's take a look at the
documentation for this guy
now it says here important note this
will be called synchronously whenever a
parameter changes and many audio
processors will change their parameters
during their audio callback
this means that this this means that not
only does your
handler code need to be completely
thread safe it's got to be very
fast and avoid blocking okay
okay what this means is that callbacks
are going to happen
on the audio thread most likely and this
means we cannot do any gui stuff
in any of these callbacks like update
the editor's filter chain here
and trigger a repaint but what we can do
is set an atomic flag that the timer can
check
and update based on that flag so that's
what we are going to do
so first things first let's copy these
callbacks all right let's go back to our
editor
all right we'll put them right here
they're no longer virtual because we are
deriving from them
let's mark this as override all right
let's go
add um let's add our timer we're going
to inherit from that so that way we can
do the atomic flag thing i'm talking
about
juice timer now we need to include the
necessary
callback we go to timer we can see the
callback is right here
virtual void and it's pure virtual so we
have to implement it
let's see all right so in this timer
callback we are going to query an atomic
flag
to decide if the chain needs updating
and our component
needs to be repainted so let's add that
atomic flag
right here below our processor
parameters
changed it's a good name for it give it
a initial value of false
all right now we don't care about um if
parameter gestures happen
so we can just give that an empty
implementation the callback parameter
that matters
is this one right here all right now
we're going to set up the
callbacks all right below our um
we're going to do this below our resized
function in the
editor.cpp so first things first let's
um
let's set up that parameter value
changed callback
parameter value changed and the only
thing we want to do
is set our atomic flag to true
next we are going to just check if it's
been changed in the callback
in the timer callback if parameters
changed dot and then here is where we
want to see if it's
true and if it is we want to set it back
to false so that way we don't
um we don't want to you know just like
always be doing this because if we don't
make any changes to the parameter we
don't need to refresh the curve
okay we're going to call that guy we
want the new value
if it is if our parameters changed is
true then we want it to be set to
false okay now if the parameters changed
we need to update the mono chain
from the ap vts we need to signal a
repaint
and yeah we need to signal a repaint so
a new response curve is drawn
unfortunately all the stuff that updates
the mono chain from the ap vts
is private in the audio processor so we
need to do some refactoring
first before we can do this and then
do this all right so let's do that next
all right head on over to
pluginprocessor.h
now all of these uh where are those
functions
okay yes all right all of these update
functions
need to be made into free functions so
if they use member variables
those member variables need to become
function arguments
so we're going to start with the
function that updates the peak filter
all right so what we will actually do is
um we're going to start by turning the
update coefficients function
into a free function and then that way
this update
peak guy can uh be turned into producing
a peak
we can change it to produce a peak
filter okay
so let's grab these guys we're going to
copy these we're going to move these
up to the top here and put it below your
chain position stuff
and we can get rid of that static
keyword and now we can make a
uh function that returns coefficients
and it makes a peak filter from chain
settings and the sample rate
all right let's go over to our plugin
processor dot cpp
we're going to go to our update peak
filter function
all right and this is where we're going
to implement that free function because
it's
just convenient to put it right there
all right so let's do
coefficients make peak filter
and this is where we want our chain
settings and our sample rate
okay so all we need to do is just return
this call
and instead of doing get sample rate we
just need to do
sample rate like that okay now we need
to
use that helper function here oh and
this needs to be um
we need to change this as well we can
just comment that out
all right so we just need to call this
function
here all right let's comment this out
and call it auto peak coefficient
equals make peak filter chain settings
get sample rate and let's do a quick
test to make sure that everything
um works as expected still
all right we're going to make sure the
peak filter works
let me open up the high pass
i hear some sleeping let's do a boost
sounds like it's working
all right cool all right next we will
get the editor to use
uh this function let's clean this up uh
let's do a little commit
since this is kind of getting into you
know micro code surgery
that sort of thing let's get rid of that
save this let's go over here
we will say refactored how peak uh
refactored
peak coefficient generation all right
that's where we did that
okay we migrated this stuff up to there
and made this uh make peak filter helper
function
yes uh then we implemented that stuff
and started using it
then here we implemented from uh
parameter listener and timer and added
the
necessary callbacks and the atomic flag
and then here is where we uh displayed
our
response curve oh that i forgot to
commit that stuff so let's do that first
all right because we want that step
separated let's see here is where we
drew our response curve
let's add it let's do that first
rendered
response curve that's going to be this
function
that's all that is that's all that is we
definitely want to separate that stuff
because that was a big chunk of code
that we wrote
okay so i was saying this is where we um
we factored the um let's see
yeah what did we do we refactored how
peak functions
uh how peak coefficients how peak
coefficients are generated refactored
how peak coefficients are generated
all right and this is where we also did
that part as well and then here is where
we
set up for uh responding to parameter
changes in the editor okay this is where
we inherited from those things this is
where we implemented the callback and
the atomic flag that we will be checking
and here is where we um updated that
flag and then
queried that flag cool
all right make your way over to the
editor
dot cpp um specifically the constructor
yes how can i can i help you okay
now that we can update any peak filter
link with the chain settings we need to
listen for when
the parameters actually change so let's
grab all the parameters from the audio
processor and add our cells as a
listener to them
all right and now let's just loop
through them uh this function returns
an array of pointers now if we register
as a listener we need to deregister as a
listener
we'll do this same chunk of code here
the new param remove listener
this okay so let's go to our timer
callback
now that we are listening to our
parameters okay
if the parameter changed we need to
update the mono chain so let's do that
let's grab the chain settings let's make
new coefficients and then let's update
our mono chain and then
repaint okay very simple auto
chain settings let's make our
coefficients
for the peak band all right our chain
settings
and our sample rate and now we can
update our
chain's coefficients our old ones are
the monochain
dot get and we want the peak
and then our replacements are going to
be these peak coefficients
all right and now we just repaint
oh i forgot to call uh coefficients
that's what we needed there we go
all right let's give that a test see if
we are there yet
all right so if i adjust this are we
seeing anything
not seeing anything
all right soon enough okay we'll get
there
we can add a debug statement ram's
changed
and we should see something down here if
we move the sliders
and we are not okay that is because
that is because we did not start our
timer
okay so we need to go up to our
constructor and start our timer
all right let's do a 60 hertz refresh
rate i knew there was something i was
forgetting
okay let's try this now this should work
perfectly all right so i'm just going to
adjust the gain
all right look at that
all right so now we need to get the cut
filters uh the cut filter functions
usable by the editor so head on over to
your plugin processor dot h
and we need to jump down to all of these
update functions
okay we need to make all of these public
so just
grab the grab these template functions
all right and we're just going to cut
them and move them up here
we can put them after our uh make peak
filter functions
uh let's do a little build just to make
sure that um we don't have to change
anything
all right those so those could have been
public from they could have been free
functions from the get-go
so now we just need to add two helper
functions
for producing the coefficients all right
so
we're going to basically do the same
thing we did this with this make peak
filter
and we're going to be able to call them
from here
so we can put them right here if we want
to implement these functions in header
files that are included
in two places such as the uh plugin
processor is included in
plugin processor.cpp and
plugineditor.cpp
and plugineditor.h if we want to do that
we need to use the inline keyword
otherwise the compiler will produce a
definition for this function
everywhere that this header file is
included and the linker will not know
which
compiled cpp file to use for the
definition
so that's why we're going to write
inline auto i'm not sure what type to
specify for
what's being returned make low cut
filter
we need our chain settings again we need
our sample rate
and then we're going to use our filter
design function again
i can just go copy this from the plug-in
processor
that's uh this thing right here let's
see i'm doing
low cut so i need this thing and here's
our sample rate
all right let's just do a quick build on
that make sure that we're not getting an
error
cool all right let's do the same thing
with the high cut
go back to plug-in processor i'm going
to copy the uh
update high cut filter is going to copy
this code over
oops this is what we want that goes here
this is get
this is just our parameter sample rate
all right and we need a return like that
format that properly and do a little
build make sure we don't have an error
okay cool now we just need to update our
call sites
head on over to the update low cut
filter function
and let's change this to make low
cut low cut filter
chain settings get sample rate
same thing for the high cut we're just
going to do make high cut get sample
rate
all right let's do a quick test before
we get the editor involved
all right this should still work
okay rolling off all the bottom as
inspected
for this one rolling off all the top end
perfect let's make a commit of that
refactor
because it's good to good to have it
okay this is where we connected our
parameters and
got the display updating all right
here's how we updated
uh let's see this is refactored how
cut filters are created that's what
happened here
get rid of that code same thing happened
here
and now this is where we um updated
let's see this is where the um gui
listens
to param changes now
cool all right we've tested our editor
now let's update the response curve all
right so go to your plugin editor dot
cpp
go to the timer callback
and we're going to do uh the same
coefficient update that we did here
so auto low cut coefficient
equals make low cut filter chain
settings
sample rate um let's cache that sample
right now i'm just
i'm feeling a little lazy i'm just going
to copy that this can all be refactored
later
so we don't dry so we don't repeat
ourselves we always want to not repeat
ourselves
dry don't repeat yourself okay here we
go auto
high cut coefficient
make high cut filter chain settings
copy that thing right there all right
now we can update our cut filter
our chain is going to be the mono chain
um we want the
low cut coefficients are going to be the
low cut coefficients
and our slope is going to be the chain
settings slope low cut
and then our update our cut filter we
can do the
high cut mono chain.get we want the high
cut position we want the high cut
coefficient
and with the high cut slope okay let's
test it out
all right so i'm going to adjust this
okay we are drawing outside of our
response area
we are drawing though that's cool so the
response area should be its own
component because
components cannot draw outside of their
balance unless you set a flag that
allows that
we will do that next but this is a good
sign that our display is responding to
controls and that what we are hearing
sounds like what we are seeing or the
other said the other way what we are
seeing
sounds like what we are hearing okay
[Music]
cool all right let's commit that
response curve now
shows cut filter response
cool
migrating this code from the editor to a
separate component
is relatively easy we need to inherit
from the things the editor is inheriting
and yeah we're really not writing any
new code
really we're just refactoring what we
already have let's go to our
header file first of all let's go up
here now we need to
basically inherit from all this stuff so
let's do that first let's do struct
uh response curve let me spell it right
it's a
component and then we need to inherit
from these things
okay we're gonna need the same uh
basically the same constructor
destructor pattern
and we're gonna need to migrate over all
of those callbacks let's just copy these
all right we're not going to need this
comment let's go to our cpp file
now our callback migration we're going
to need our parameter changed in our
timer callback
so i'm just going to copy these two guys
directly move them up to the top
put them up here and just change this to
response
curve component same for that we get a
bunch of error messages
it's fine we'll fix those in just a
second and we need to migrate over the
code
that registered as a listener so let's
do that
here let's give ourselves uh let's see
we need to
initialize we need to provide ourselves
with that same um
same the same thing okay now we can
initialize that guy
audio processor all right now
we need to migrate over the code that
registered as a listener
okay so let's do that next where was
that found
that was all of this stuff right here
it's name for the timer we need that too
those guys go there
we need the destructor we need that code
all right so let's copy this okay we're
going to need a paint function
so let's declare one of those void paint
we can just migrate over the entire
paint function from the plugin editor
so we can literally just rename this
i'm not going to do that though i'm
going to copy it and do the proper thing
but literally we can just literally copy
this whole thing and put it down here
we'll fix all those variables in just a
second
all those error messages number eight we
need to migrate over the parameter
changed atomic
value so let's grab this from here
that should go here we also need to
migrate over our chain
now once we've done these things we need
to we need to
give ourselves an instance so let's do
that um
i'm just going to put that here response
curve
component and then we can also get rid
of our chain
we can also get rid of our atomic in our
plugin editor.cpp we need to go down to
our function here and add it
as one of our components all right now
we need to initialize it
so let's go do that in our um
editor constructor pretty sure it's
going to tell me that it needs to be
initialized before
the other response curve component audio
processor
yes this needs to be initialized before
uh the attachment
for all the attachments finally we need
to give it some bounds so let's go to
our plug-in editor resized function
and now we can actually use our response
area
cool all right so let's go to our plugin
editor
all right this is not going to inherit
from uh parameter listener or timer
anymore
so we don't need any of these callbacks
um we don't need this atomic we don't
need
uh the chain so that means we can get
rid of these
uh get rid of those functions as well
all right so let's go to our plugin
editor.cpp
uh we are no longer listening for those
and we're not a timer anymore
so those go away same for the destructor
stuff
and then we're not doing any of this so
we can just continue
filling it entirely with black so we can
get rid of
all of this stuff and then we don't need
our
this callback that disappears
all right and i believe that's most of
the errors let's build it and see what
it tells us
that may have been it all right yep okay
all right
so let's run and test it all right so
this is tiny for some reason that's way
smaller than we wanted
let's go to our resized function uh
bounce remove from top
bounds dot get height oh you know why
it's because um our response area here
in this um our response area should not
be
33 of the actual component it should
just be the get local bounce so i'm just
going to get
do that and then get rid of this line
all right now if we run it we should be
good to go
okay cool so let's check if we are
drawing outside of our bounds anymore
and no we are not so that's fantastic
i told you that would be easy okay let's
commit that change
oh created response curve component
that's a fairly uh fairly aggressive
amount of code surgery here's our
response curve component with all the
good stuff in it
here's where we gutted the editor
same for right here all right we've come
a long way we've done a lot of stuff
okay we are going to customize the
slider visuals now
for this slider class i want it to show
the following okay i want to see the min
and max range at either end of the
slider and i want to see the parameters
value in the center of the slider
i want the slider to have some
customized visuals outside of those
pieces of text
so i'm going to change this slider class
let me go to my editor first i'm going
to change this
slider class right here to have a custom
look and feel that will do those things
so a bit of planning before we actually
start
and the juice look and feel system works
as follows
let me jump to that okay
here we go all right look and feel
methods for these slider clasps
now the look and feel system works as
follows
okay inside the component paint function
let me go to slider or paint
all right here's what happens in the
look and feel system
when you're painting your components now
things are a little bit different with
the slider paint but
the general practice works like this in
your components paint function
you're going to call get look and feel
and then
inside of that you're going to call
one of the look and feel member
functions sorry in the look and feel
class
there are several member functions for
drawing different things and it's the
way it's organized is kind of strange
basically like we're in the slider class
the slider has look and feel methods
there's a look and feel bass class which
inherits from all of these
narratives from all these things i can
pull it up in the docs and you'll see
what i'm talking about if we go over
here
okay so you can see the look and feel
class inherits from all of these
different base classes you know button
has look and feel methods
text editor has their own tree view
slider
label tool tip window okay
so what happens is the components they
get their look and feel
instance and then they call one of these
look and feel methods
so let me go to the slider.cpp and show
you what i'm talking about
in the sliders case it uses a pimple to
deal with the implementation so i'm
going to go to
that so we can see what's going on okay
so
as shown here it's using a look and feel
instance and it is calling
one of those look and feel member
functions okay
i'll go back to this so we can see what
i'm talking about uh slider look and
feel methods
okay here we go draw a linear slider the
thumb
if it's like a slider that's got
multiple thumbs and stuff on it if it's
a rotary slider a button
where to draw the text box what kind of
text box to
display that sort of thing okay so it's
going to call one of these
member functions and then inside this
member function is where all that stuff
gets painted
okay so for example the vertical slider
is going to call get look and feel in
the paint function if i go back here
all right here's the get look and feel
it's going to pass it to the pimples
paint function
all right and then that's going to call
draw linear slider
okay on that returned object okay now
the idea is that anything you want to
draw on the actual
slider part of the component is drawn
with that look and feel member function
everything that is drawn outside of it
is drawn in the component's paint
function
okay regardless of that i don't want to
get lost in those
details as i said everything that is
drawn outside of
the slider area is going to be drawn
in um it's going to be drawn in the
paint function everything that's part of
the slider is going to be drawn in the
get look and feel draw rotary slider
function okay
now i want the parameter value to be
displayed in the center of the slider
so for this reason i am going to display
that in the look and feel member
function since i consider it to be part
of the slider itself
okay i'm going to draw the min and max
parameters in the paint function
and call that look and feel member
function from the paint function
okay i know i need a bit of room for the
text labels showing the range to be
within this component
so that means the actual area that the
slider will be drawn in needs to be
smaller
than the component itself i'm also going
to want to use a uniform text height for
all of the text
displayed here so i'm going to need a
function that's going to give me that as
well
okay now the reason for this is because
my paint function and the look and feel
member function
will need to call this get text type
function since i'm going to be drawing
text
in both places and i want it to just
look consistent
okay i also want to customize the suffix
that is displayed for each parameter
so this way i will see things like 2.85
kilohertz or 12 db per octave
all right we will figure out what to do
for the quality parameter when we get to
that stage
since that doesn't have any units at all
okay and then finally i'm going to need
i'm going to need a parameter so that
way i can get its value so let's go back
to our plugin editor
all right so we're going to just this
class is going to have a lot of surgery
done in it okay
first let's rename this class and we're
going to call this
rotary slider with labels okay
so the next thing we need is we need to
give ourselves a parameter and a suffix
like i had said
so juice ranged audio parameter
we're gonna do pointer to it the only
the reason i'm using this thing
is because this this is the base class
for all of these um all of these guys
even though and it derives from audio
processor parameter and it contains a
whole bunch of member functions that
let me pull information out of this if i
go take a look at it
there's like let's see they're like i'm
going to need these convert to
zero to one and convert from zero to one
that sort of thing and then there's a
whole bunch of like you know get value
and all this kind of stuff
that it comes from the base class okay
getting a little sidetracked some
let's not get too lost in the minutia
about that and just focus on following
the code that is going to be written
all right so there's my parameter i'm
going to give myself a suffix
all right now i'm going to update this
constructor
to initialize these two member variables
all right and now
let's let's populate that
guy okay now we actually need a
look and feel class okay we need an
actual look and feel class that we can
provide our um draw rotary slider
function all right if we jump back over
to
um jump back over to this thing this is
where i can
go to that slider class here's the look
and feel methods
so we want to implement a rotary slider
function okay so that's what we need to
provide here let's make a look and feel
all right these inherit from uh there's
a few different versions we're going to
inherit from the most recent one
look and feel the version four and
then this is where we are going to
implement draw rotary slider
so let's go to the slider class and
look for that look and feel methods
and we're gonna draw that uh rotary
slider so just copy this guy
declare it here override it and give
ourselves a default implementation for
right now
and then make this um we gotta have that
juice name space
cool all right we have our look and feel
object
or our look and feel class we need to
give ourselves an instance
and then we can set that as our look and
feel object
set look and feel lnf
all right now if we are setting a look
and feel we have to remember to
unset it in our destructor
now as i said we're going to need a
paint function because we're going to
have some custom visuals
so let's do that void paint
i had said we're going to need the
slider bounds which is going to be
smaller than
what we're actually going to it's going
to be slightly smaller than the
component bounds itself so we need
some function that can provide that
juice
rectangle we're going to need that text
height
so um that's just going to be an integer
and then we're going gonna need to get
that display string
okay that's what that's what's gonna
show us that kilohertz
or db per octave or
um you know decibels if we're doing the
gain slider okay so let's do
juice string get display
string like that okay now
did all of these change if we go down to
our plugin editor.h go way down here
all of these rotary slider with labels
yes they are okay
all right now we need to initialize all
of these guys so go to plugineditor.cpp
go to the constructor
and all these are declared before the
response curve so they need to be
initialized before the response curve
okay now if you remember this thing
needs um
this thing needs uh what's it called it
needs its parameter
and then it also needs the suffix that's
going to get displayed at the end
so let's do the first one so that's
going to be peak freak slider
so the wants a parameter so let's
use our ap vts to get a parameter
and we already know the name this is the
peak frequency slider so it's going to
be called peak freak
and the suffix is going to be hertz
capital h
okay that's one slider we got to do the
rest of them
oh this one's a reference not a pointer
so we different
dereference that okay let's do the rest
of these guys
and then we need our our units all right
this is decibels quality has no units
frequency also frequency
and then the decibels per
oct same thing for this one
okay if we build it we should not have
any errors
oh we have an error what's the problem
what happened undefined symbol
why did that give us an undefined symbol
oh we're missing a pain function
that's why okay let's go to our plugin
editor dot
um dot h and
our paint function needs an
implementation
so just we'll just leave it empty for
right now
all right awesome build succeeded okay
so if we run this
we're not going to our sliders are going
to be blank because their look and feel
is
uh null is um drawing this
our pain function is empty okay so
that's why we don't see any sliders
right now
but that's okay because we implemented
the skeleton so we can start drawing
this stuff
all right let's make a commit of that
implemented
skeleton for custom slider
visuals all right here's our where we
set up the parameters
here's where we did all this code
surgery it doesn't look like we wrote
very much but
it's a lot you know it's a fairly big
design change
first thing we are going to do is make
this just a declaration and we will also
do that with our
draw rotary slider all right now let's
go to our paint function
which we need to implement now so let's
put this at the top
let's use one of these to add a space
visual delineation so let's implement
that paint function first
floyd rotary slider with
labels paint
we're going to use that namespace trick
okay we will begin by setting up the
rotary slider to
visually have a range of seven o'clock
to five o'clock okay seven o'clock so
here's 12
we're gonna go seven all the way to five
this is probably backwards for you with
camera but for me
i'm looking at it if i had a clock in
front of me this would be
seven o'clock and then this would be
twelve uh five o'clock
okay seven o'clock will be where the
slider draws the value of zero
five o'clock will be where it draws the
value of one so let's
start by setting up some angles that
represent seven o'clock and five o'clock
and remember that twelve o'clock is zero
degrees and we have to use radians here
which is annoying auto start ang
equals degrees to radians thank
thankfully that function exists okay we
want 180.f
plus 45 degrees
all right so this is 12 this is gonna be
180
and then we're gonna go halfway uh so
it's more like 7 30 not seven
but either way you know like this this
would be nine o'clock
this is six o'clock so 7 30 is
45 degrees away okay that's the start
angle
our end angle is going to be going this
way and because we need it to be bigger
than this side we have to go
one circle around which is two pi and
then
go 180 minus 45. okay
so auto and equals
uh this same value but going
the other way and then added a um added
with a full
rotation now the
draw rotary slider function wants a
normalized value
passed to it so we will use the sliders
range for that
and then even though we haven't
implemented this let's prepare for this
and just assume we'll be drawing the
rotary part of the slider inside the
slider bounce so auto slider bounds
equals get slider bounce okay let's
implement that
now all right let's put that right here
i remember this is const oh let's just
make it return local bounds for right
now we will
adjust this later so we have some basic
information we can call the look and
feel function
now so get our look and feel
and now draw rotary slider and now we
just start filling this in okay first
thing is g
for the graphic context x is going to be
our slider bounds
x position same for the y
same for the width same for the height
our slider position proportional
if you don't forget that we said we
needed a normalized value here so we're
going to
map the slider's value we're going to
map the
slider's value from the start of the
range
to the end of the range and we need to
map it from 0
to 1 all right and then our start angle
we already have that and our end angle
and then our slider is
this okay that's a lot
that's an annoying function to look at
and fill in all the blanks if you don't
know what you're looking at
all right the important thing is this
one this line right here this is where
we map
our sliders this is where we turn our
sliders value into a normalized value
so now that we've done this we can
implement the draw rotary slider
function let's do that up here void
look and feel draw rotary come on
autocomplete
all right let's put that all on its own
lines
all right we'll do the same using j uh
namespace juice trick here's what we're
going to do
in this draw rotary slider class we're
going to fill a circle
and it's going to act as the slider
background we're going to draw a border
around that circle
and we're going to convert the sliders
normalized value to an
angle in radians and that's going to be
between the rotary start angle and the
rotary end angle
we're going to create a small vertical
rectangle and then we're going to rotate
it to the angle
in radians and then draw it okay so
let's do the first thing
before we do anything else we need a
bounding box
here we've got our x y width
height okay so let's first create some
circles that represent the rotariness
of the slider now for these colors i
just used the
app digital color meter
and it lets me you know just pick some
random colors that i like
you know maybe i like this yellow color
maybe i like this greenish color
or this color right here that's what i
use to pick my colors so i'm just going
to type in what i picked prior
and use them here so g dot set color
i don't know what that looks like right
now i just know that when i
first sketched this project out i liked
that
after i found it somewhere okay so g dot
fill ellipse
and this is where we want fill the
bounding box
let's do the same thing again with a
different color and we're going to draw
the ellipse which is going to give us
the border
we said we were going to create let's
take a look at that we'll just see some
circles
cool circles let's make a narrow
rectangle that goes from the center of
the bounding box
up to the 12 o'clock position now if we
want to rotate
something that's going to be drawn we
have to define it
inside of a path so let's create a path
now
and i like using the rectangle member
functions to define
rectangles as opposed to using the
rectangle class constructor
that takes an x y width and height
because it just seems
easier to visualize mentally where
things are going to be
okay so i'm gonna do that rectangle
float r the
left and the right are gonna be a couple
of pixels off
of the center so we can do r dot set
left
so we can do center dot get x
and then two pixels off of that we can
do r dot set the right side
center dot get x two pixels to the right
of center
and then we'll just make the top be the
bounds
top will be the top and the bottom will
be the center okay so r dot set top
this is going to be bounds dot get y
and then r dot set bottom is going to be
center dot get y now let's add it to our
path p dot add rectangle
now we get ready to rotate so the first
thing we want to make sure
is that this thing is less than this
thing otherwise we'll get some weird
explosions so let's just add a quick j
assert for that
rotary start angle it's less than rotary
end
angle this is what i was saying of how
we needed to add
a full cycle to it because otherwise we
would have 180 minus 45 as our start
or 180 plus 45 which is like 225 or
something
and then this one would give us like um
135 which is
less than this it becomes a problem when
we do our jmap
so now we need to map our slider's
normalized value to a radian
angle right so we've got autoslider
angle in radians is jmap
are we are mapping from our slider
position proportional
from a value of 0.0 to 0.1
and we're going to map it from i'm sorry
that should be 0.f
that's one dot f our target major in is
going
our target range min is going to be the
uh
rotary start angle and our end range is
going to be the rotary
end angle okay so we are mapping
our normalized slider value to be
between
these two rotary positions which we
defined here
we can rotate the narrow rectangle to
this
radian angle using an afine transform
and we have to do it around the center
of our component
all right so p dot apply transform
here's we want an
a fine transform we're going to rotate
it
we want the one that allows us to rotate
it around a particular location
we've got our angle in radians and our
pivot point is going to be
center dot get x center dot get y
now we just need to draw it let's build
and test
just remember you know they're not we're
not we're just drawing them within their
bounding box
okay but it is doing it and the when the
value is zero
the notch is straight up and down so
that's
cool all right so as i said let's see
this is where it's at the five o'clock
position
here's where it's at the seven o'clock
position so
awesome okay so they look a little wonky
let's fix
that next but they are working
okay we've implemented a customized look
and feel
the next thing i would like to do is add
the center label
showing the parameters value next
okay we'll figure out that bounding
issue in a minute as well
let's make a commit of that added basic
slider visuals here's where we
made these deck made these
implementations into declarations
then here's where we implemented our
first basic
paint function which calls the rotary
slider
and then here in the rotary sliders
where we actually draw
the things okay okay let's start by
drawing the slider bounds and start
tweaking the get
slider bounds function until it gives us
a
usable size okay so let's go to where
we're getting our slider bounds
and let's draw yes let's
draw the slider bounds as well as our
local bounds so
g dot set color red and we'll draw our
local bounds and then we'll use a
different color for the slider bounds
now uh before we start tweaking this
let's just shrink this a little bit
okay we're gonna want a square so our
ellipses are actually
circles so let's do auto size equals
um and we'll find the minimum dimension
of whatever bounding box is returned to
us
all right so we've got our bounds dot
get width balance don't get height
oh we need to get rid of this line
that's right okay so auto bounds
equals get local bounce so now
we know we're going to display some text
on either edge of it
so let's shrink our bounding box by that
size
let's shrink our size our square size by
that much so we'll do size
minus equals get text height do it
times two all right now we just need to
move it
towards the top of our component we need
to move our
slider bounds towards the top so let's
create a rectangle that has
our size but the top of it is it's so
that it's positioned at the top of our
component
so juice rectangle
r dot set size give it a size of
give it a width and height of size so
it's a square
and then we need to set um i don't know
what
x and y to give it for the actual
position because that's based on the
upper left corner but i can specify
where the center is and that's not going
to change the size
so i'm going to do that r dot set center
i know i want that to be bounds dot get
center x
so that's going to put it in the center
it's going to put the center of this
rectangle in the center of my component
and then i can set the y position
accordingly r dot
set y zero or just below the top i'm not
going to do zero i'm going to do two so
it's two pixels below the top of the
component
and the sent the center of our rectangle
is going to be in the center of our
component
now let's just return it let's build and
test it
boom circles at the top slightly below
the edge
and they're in a square bounding box
awesome
all right let's make a commit of that
because that's helpful
all right uh sliders are now
circles oh let's get rid of this
um this line right there let's amend
that commit
oh wait no i don't want to amend it
sliders are now circles
there we go okay let's display the
parameter in the center
next we will keep the circles for right
now let's go to our
look and feel we're gonna keep these
circles that are being drawn
uh but for now we need uh the text
height from our slider as well as the
text itself
so we already had some stubs for these
functions in place
when we decided we were to do
get text height and then get display
string right because we wanted to be
able to figure out you know what do we
display in the center
so in order for us to call that we need
to
get a rotary slider with labels out of
this parameter
so to do that we are going to have to
cast
okay so after we get our um after we
draw our circles
we'll do a cast all right if we can cast
it then we know we can call those
functions all right so this is where we
can
do this put that there we're going to
need our same path and our same
rectangle stuff
all right and then actually since our
text is going to be in the center we
need to adjust the bottom of our narrow
rectangle so that it does
not cover it up so it's going to be
centered i get y
minus um let's see
yeah the bottom it's no longer going to
be the center it's going to be the
center
uh sorry it's not gonna going to be the
bottom of our
bounding box oh yes sorry it's going to
be um it's going to be where our center
is and then we're going to subtract the
text height
which will put us back towards the top
because top is 0
get height is the bottom okay so we're
going to the center
and we're going to go uh up by
subtracting
some text height amount okay so we'll
just do uh
rs rswl
get text height and then
uh maybe that much maybe two
we'll have to see how it looks okay all
right so this is where i'm gonna change
this from being a regular rectangle
i'm gonna add a rounded rectangle p dot
add rounded rectangle because
you know let's dial it up a little bit
our let's do a corner size of two
all right now this is where we do all of
our rotation stuff
so now let's make a now let's make a
little rectangle that's a little bit
wider than our text
and a little bit taller than our text is
so that way we can
have a nice we know how roughly how much
text
we're going to need to display so let's
make a bounding box that fits around it
and then we're going to put that right
in the center of our
slider okay so let's first get let's
first
set our font accordingly and we're going
to just use that text height as the font
it's going to keep displaying whatever
default font is currently being used
rswl
get text height all right this is going
to give us
this is going to use the default font at
this height
all right now let's get our text and
then let's get our string width
string width
equals g dot get current font
get string width text
okay that tells us how wide we are all
right we can use this
same rectangle so r dot set size
we're going to go str width a little bit
wider than that
and then the font height our swl
get text height oops get text height
a little bit taller than that okay so
now we've got our
rectangle r is now has this bound it's
it's gonna basically be a little bit
bigger than uh
the bounding box for our text okay we
need to just set the center of it to be
the center of our bounds right here
our dot set center center
that's this guy right here or if we
don't trust that we can always write
bounds not get center
all right and then let's just make a
black background for right now
g dot set color colors black
and then uh we're gonna fill it in uh g
dot phil rect
r okay now
let's use white text and just paint our
text inside of that
so g dot set color colors white
and then g.draw fitted text
our text inside of r and r is a float
rectangle so we need to
get it to um an int to let's see what do
we got two nearest in
good enough and then we want it centered
choose justification
centered and one line of text
now it's not going to build because we
haven't implemented yet display string
yet
okay so we need to implement that next
all right let's put this near where um
we build our uh
build our slider bounds all right so
juice string
rotary slider get display string
this was const if you remember and we
will
just do return juice
string and we're just going to return
our sliders value
let's build and test we should see a
rectangle in all black with white text
in the center of every slider
showing some numeric value okay cool
so we got twenty thousand
it's working as expected all right this
is giving us one two
three these are the indexes in that
string array
of choices we created at the very
beginning here's our q
alright and here's our here's our gain
for our slider okay cool so we are not
seeing suffixes but we are seeing our
values okay the only thing we're not
seeing is the proper slope okay we
should be seeing 12 24 36 48.
we will deal with that next let's make a
commit of that
displaying basic param values
cool okay we are trying to represent
two parameter types a float param and a
choice param
and the choice param has a list that we
can use
directly if our parameter is a choice
then let's just use that choice param so
let's get rid of this line
and we can do if auto choice param
equals dynamic cast um let's see
juice audio parameter choice
if we can convert our ranged audio
parameter to an audio parameter choice
then just return that choice param get
uh what's it called get current choice
name
now for the gain and the hertz
parameters we need to amend our suffix
to the parameter value
also i want to truncate the hertz value
if the frequency is over 1000 so that it
says kilohertz
instead so first we need a string object
for that
and if we and then we need to specify if
we're going to add uh the k or not
so let's assume we are not going to okay
now i don't like to make guesses about
what type of derived class my parameter
actually is
so i'm going to use a cast here to check
if it's actually an audio parameter
float
now i know i haven't added any other
parameter
types in this project but just in case
i'm going to add a little j assert
in case one happens to sneak in later in
the project all right so
if it's this i know i'm cool
otherwise j assert false
if you recall the values that our
parameter ranges had
you know that the hertz parameter is the
only one that can possibly get over
1000 so that means we can just check if
our value is
over that and then divide by a thousand
to get a kilohertz value
once we have that then we can say yes
please add a
k to the suffix and we can convey that
with that boolean flag we used earlier
so if value uh first we need to get our
value
float value equals getvalue if
our value is greater than um if our
value is
over is 1000 or higher
then um this is when we want to display
it as kilohertz so we will say
vowel divided by equals
divided by a thousand so if it's
um if the value is one thousand hertz
we're going to see
one k h z like this add
true okay now the string class
in juice has a constructor which lets
you convert
a floating point number into a string
and one of the parameters is how many
decimal places to use
now if i'm displaying a value as
kilohertz i only want to see
two decimal places we already know that
dividing um
one thousand and one divided by a
thousand is going to give us
let's see one thousand one thousand one
divided by one thousand
will give us one point zero zero i don't
want to see that okay i just want to see
two decimal places
so according to this constructor let me
pull that up real quick
this one right here float value okay
it says number of decimal places if this
number is greater than zero
the number will be formatted using that
many decimal places
adding trailing zeros if required if the
number is zero or less
the number will be formatted using the c
plus plus
standard library default format which
uses scientific notation for large and
small
numbers according to the documentation
if you go back over here according to
the documentation for this constructor
if a 0 is provided for the number of
decimal places
the number will be formatted uh using
the stl with however many decimal places
are needed so this will work out when we
are displaying
decibels or quality versus the hertz
okay so we're going to do str equals
juice string
um where is that one it's down here
somewhere
this one float okay our float val
for our number of decimal places if we
are adding the k
we want to see two decimal places
otherwise the
stl formatting is will be just fine
so add add k for adding the k give me
two decimal places otherwise
give me however many are actually needed
to display the parameters value
all right now the final thing is that we
had said that the quality property
does not have any units which means we
did not supply a suffix if you go back
down
here you'll see what i'm talking about
okay
hertz and decibels have a suffix but
quality does not have a suffix
so if the suffix is not empty
let's add a space after the number and
then add the suffix
if suffix is not empty
we can do str um add the space
and then um if we are doing a hertz
value which is over one kilohertz let's
add the k
if add k str
add that little k like that now we just
add the suffix and then we're done
return the string okay
let's run that and check it out
boom 121hz and let's raise that to be
over a thousand
there we go 1.01
awesome okay and then these guys
cool all right i'm not too mad about
when it's showing a negative and
it's not showing the um uh
it's not showing it the rectangle is
changing size it's you know
that's just like a minor detail that we
don't need to fix and now this is
displaying
the correct slope values so that's cool
all right let's ditch those bounding
boxes that we're showing the rectangles
it's these guys right here i'm gonna
leave them in as comments though
um because you know if we ever need to
debug this some more it's
good to just you know it makes it easy
to uncomment them and display them later
let's take a look one more time and see
what we've got all right that's nice and
clean
cool let's make a commit of that
alright so implemented implemented
displaying the parameter value
with suffix
cool let's add the labels next that will
show the minimum and maximum values that
our parameters can have
i would like the minimum value to be
drawn right outside of that
seven o'clock position on the slider and
the maximum value
to be drawn outside of the five o'clock
position here is how i have decided to
go about implementing this
okay we're going to have a simple data
structure which will hold a normalized
value
and the string that should be positioned
at that normalized position
okay so we'll put that let's see let me
go to a plugin editor.h
all right we're going to put that right
here okay so we'll do struct
label position give it that normalized
value
and then the string that's going to get
displayed
all right now that we have this
structure we can just give ourselves an
array of them
and then all we have to do is add some
values to that array and then draw them
in our paint function all right let's
make our way over to the
paint function okay we're going to draw
this after we draw our slider
so let's see what we need to do is
create a bounding box that can
encompass our text and then put the
center of that bounding box at whatever
normalized position we decided
we have decided on around our sliders
circumference
once we have that bounding box we can
just use the graphics function
draw fitted text like we did right here
we can do the same thing to we can do
that to draw our label inside the
bounding box
so first things first let's get the
center and radius of
our slider bounce auto center
equals slider bounds dot to float
dot get center okay we want this in
floating point numbers and then let's
get the radius from that
auto radius equals slider bounds
dot get width and then give me half of
that
okay now let's set up the text color and
size of the text
i'm going to use the same text color uh
no i'm gonna use a different text color
i'm gonna use like a greenish looking
thing
again i figured this out using that
digital
color meter app this thing right here i
found a nice green that i liked
and just jotted down the rgb values
let's do that next
g dot set color i've got a value of zero
unsigned in value of 127
172 right here for that and then
one for the blue and then we need to set
our font
okay we're going to use the default font
with this text height
we need to iterate through our labels so
auto num
choices equals labels.size
and here we go four int i
equals zero i is less than num choices
plus i all right now let's convert that
normalized position into a radian
angle auto position equals
labels okay and we want to make sure
that it's between zero and one just in
case
all right now let's j-map it like we j
mapped um
this thing right here actually we can
just grab this
auto angle equals this thing and this is
going to be our
position and our start ang is going to
be
um what we set up here same for the
rotary
end okay now we can use one of the
point class member functions uh
particularly this one
point um
i'll show you the member function get
point on circumference we can use this
member function
to find the center point we will use for
this bounding box with
this particular radian angle we have our
center that we will use
so center dot get point on circumference
our radius is going to be um
radius plus get text height
yeah we want it to be a little bit
further out from our um
rectangle so we'll do like half
the um text height maybe a little bit of
a another question
and then our angle is gonna be like that
so if you're wondering where this
number came from let me turn this back
on and
draw this okay so i'm talking about
here's our center of um that bounding
box we're gonna go
if if i go if i go radius away from this
at this
angle i'm gonna end up like right at
this point right here so that's why i'm
adding text height to it
because text height is this amount so i
want to go that much more
away that's going to kind of put me near
this corner right
it's going to be different you know it's
not going to be it's going to be like
this
vertical distance away from this angle
that's why that's going to do that
that's what this line of code does it's
going to get me that point
auto c equals that okay we have our
center point
now we can get the width of our string
from the currently used font like we did
up here i'm going to do that same same
thing right here
and then we're going to make a rectangle
that's going to use that
width as well as our text height to
define its bounce so let's do
rectangle float r um we need our label
uh do we need that yet yes we need our
label because we need to do r
dot set size so auto str equals
labels label okay and then we can do r
dot set size
now we will use the size using that get
string width helper function like we
showed before
uh this is going to be g dot get current
font get
string width str and then our height is
going to be get
text height now we can just set our
center r dot set center
and then um maybe shift it down a little
bit
just in case so it doesn't collide r dot
set y
okay we'll get the current y as it is r
dot get y
and we'll just add a little bit um you
know just shift it down just a little
bit more
okay and then now we can just draw our
fitted text and hopefully this will be
in the right position
okay so g.draw fitted text
our text is going to be our string area
is going to be r
r is a float rectangle type so we want
to
get the nearest end we need to convert
it to integers
we'll do the same centered and
one line try to fit all the text on one
line okay so just to recap
we are drawing where we've got the
center of our rectangle
right here we're going to go at some
angle away from it
like this and then this would put us
right on the edge of the circle and we
don't want our rectangle to be centered
on the edge of that circle we want it to
be
a little bit further out and then down a
little bit so that way it doesn't
collide with the circle
okay so this uh this gets it right on
the circle
this gets it a little bit past the
circle and then this
shifts it down from the circle all right
let's check that out
okay why is this not displaying anything
oh because we didn't initialize it
duh we need to actually provide some
labels first so let's do that next
36 step number 36 so we need to go to
step number 37.
let's go to our constructor in our um
where is this this is in our plug-in
editor
plug-in editor okay so we will do this
before we make our components visible
let's add um our min and max ranges so
we'll start with the peak freq
peak freak slider okay and this is where
we'll go to our labels and
we'll just add one of these label
positions so
at position zero i want to display 20
hertz and then at position 1.0 we will
display
uh 20 kilohertz
and then we'll do khc like that let's
see if that looks like anything
okay cool 20 hertz 20 kilohertz nice
all right let's make a commit of that
ram
min max values stage stage
all right let's do the rest of them we
got 20
um let's see negative 24 db and plus 24.
okay cool so my gain slider uh whoops i
always spell that wrong
okay so my gain slider is going to show
negative 24 and plus 24.
my quality will show 0.1 and 10.0
and then low cut and high cut are going
to show 20 hertz and 20 kilohertz
and then the um slope sliders are going
to show
12 and 48 and i don't think there i
don't see a need to make it display the
decibels per octave thing um anyway
let's run it and check it out
okay oh let's get rid of these bounding
boxes where was that that's up here
somewhere
that's right here they're handy to have
um handy to be able to just pop them in
there to help debug your visuals
okay cool that's looking pretty clean
i'm happy with that
all right let's adjust these positions a
little bit uh let's
adjust these positions a little bit i'm
going to make the display a little bit
taller
and then and i'm going to do that
because let me put that back
okay it's a little it's a little bit
cramped for me here
so i'm going to make this just a little
bit taller
and then we're going to use juice live
constant here i want to
change the height of the response
area okay so get a little look at how
that's done
so we'll do float h ratio height ratio
i'm going to use juice live constant
here um
we're currently using 33 okay
so now we can do this here and we're
gonna dial in
our height ratio to figure out what size
the response area should be
okay cool so now we are looking at
what am i adjusting
all right okay i'm doing that because
when this goes like that it covers up
that
so if i shrink this a little bit does
that go away
all right that seems okay i need the
slider
text to not overlap but it's doing it
anyway so
perhaps i need to shrink this length so
it's a little bit smaller
or maybe it's not a thing either way 25
percent looks good the knobs are a
little bit bigger
i mean if we wanted to we could just
make this like really big but that just
looks kind of weird and we don't even
see our slider thumbnail
so that's the big problem is i want to
see more of the slider's thumb
than i'm currently seeing right now
which is why i'm making
if that's like that i want to make this
a little bit
i want to see more of the thumb okay so
i think 25 looks okay
makes it's pretty easy to see where the
thumb is okay
so we'll stick with that we'll do 25 for
that value
okay so we'll change this to 25.f
divided by 100.f and we'll just comment
out because it's always you know it's
always useful to be able to uncomment
that and use it to dial in those other
positions
okay now i think if we take a look at
that
there's one other graphic change i want
to make
now i don't like this gap right here so
i want to put a little bit of room
between where the sliders are
and where this component where this
response curve component ends
so we can do that by just removing a
little bit from
this bounce before we do all of this
stuff
that's pretty easy bounce dot remove
from top
i'm gonna just remove five pixels
let's see what that looks like okay
that's
yeah that's clean i'm happy with that
okay
so let's open this up now i'm gonna
let's see what this does
i'm just gonna customize this a little
bit save it
close this okay so these parameters are
not
drawn on here right away okay so that's
a bug that we need to fix
so let's uh let's open this back up
let's quit this
let's see if we can solve that okay so
this is caused
let's go look at our um timer callback
code response curve command okay the
chain is only updated
whenever the timer callback
determines that this parameter is true
and this parameter is only set to true
whenever the parameter values change so
if our gui is displayed
have the parameters changed from the
since they're
since they were initially loaded no they
have not
okay so there's a couple ways we can do
this um
first of all the hacky way
to do this would be to say you know what
this parameter
has changed the first time the gui loads
but that's
kind of hacky okay what we need to do is
just refactor how
that stuff gets set in the first place
so let's
make an update chain function
and now we can just call this in our
timer callback
and from our constructor all right so
this is going to update the chain during
construction which means the chain will
give us the proper magnitude values
when we paint it for the very first time
so let's do that let's add a uh
let's put that right here okay we're
just going to move that code out of
timer call back
void response curve component update
chain we can just grab all this stuff
we're not going to repaint though okay
now we're just going to call it
update chain and then we can call it in
our constructor as well
let's call it before we do our timer
all right let's run it and we should see
uh the chain get updated automatically
whenever we close and reopen the gui
okay so that's showing up is correct i'm
going to change this param to that
okay that's on 90b so notice there's a
bump right there i'm going to close this
gui
reopen it and that bump is there cool
bug solved all right let's make a commit
to that
what do we have going on here uh fixed
response curve bug
when first when um first
opening the gui okay cool so
we have our um this is where we started
displaying the
star values and then this is where we
actually added
those labels here's where we dialed in
the um the final position for all the
components and then here's where we
fixed the response curve issue by
refactoring what happens in timer
callback into its own function
that we can call from our constructor
okay cool that wraps up the
response curve and customizing the knob
visuals okay the next thing to do is to
put a grid
behind the response curve and then after
we do that we can add the
spectrum analyzer and then after we do
that we can add the bypass buttons
okay so we got three big things to do
before we are done with this component
but we are
almost done with this project so
awesome it's progressing very quickly
at a pretty good clip
okay let's give this response curve a
proper background component
that's going to show the frequency plot
and since we don't need to recreate this
every time the curve is updated we are
going to
pre-render it into an image so let's
head over to our plugin editor.h
and we will do that right here
now we need a place to make this
background image
and the resized function is a good place
to do this because
it is called whenever the component
bounds change and it is called before
the first time that paint is called
so let's declare that guy here all right
let's go to our cpp file
let's put this after our paint function
the first thing we will do in this
resized function
is make a new background image based on
the width and height of our
component okay so first let's declare
this void
uh response curve component resized
so okay we're going to create a new
background image then we will create a
graphics context
which we'll draw into this background
image and then from there we can just do
the usual paint stuff
except we are drawing into this
background image
directly using the graphics context that
we created so let's start
we'll start with that okay we're going
to use an rgb context
an rgb pixel format the width and the
height for the dimensions and then we
want to clear the background
all right now we just need the graphics
context
now i want to draw frequency lines
so i'm going to create an array that i
can loop through and convert these
frequencies to window space and then
draw them as
vertical lines and these values that i'm
using for the frequencies are the
standard values people use when
producing these types of plots
yeah i mean you can come up with
whatever you want but these are the
pretty standard
um values that people use and they're in
multiples of 10.
uh are they um they um they scale up
by a factor of 10 each time so let's do
uh
so i'm going to do 20 30 40 50
100. i'm gonna multiply that uh by
uh 10 and then the last one
since that's the top of the human
hearing range
all right now i'm going to uh set my
color to white i'm going to loop through
the frequencies i'm going to
map them from i'm going to map them from
this frequency linear
space to a normalized position and then
i'm going to draw a vertical line
all right let's take a look at that uh
i'm sorry actually
uh before we even do that um
we need to display it in pain but before
i do that i want to
show some gain lines as well so i'm
going to do the same thing
i'm going to create an array i'm going
to loop through it and i'm going to draw
i'm going to convert each value in the
array to
a window position and then draw it as a
horizontal line
so let's create that next
i'm going to do i'm going to do lines
every 12 decibels
okay so remember i'm using 24
and negative 24 as my range because
that's what our
slider can um our gain slider can
those are the ranges of that gain slider
and then it's important to remember that
the bottom
of the window at the bottom we want this
negative 24 to be mapped to the bottom
of our component
and then we want the positive 24 to be
mapped to the top of our component
and then we're just drawing a horizontal
line from the left side
to the right side all right now we just
need to go to our paint function
and draw it in the background
g dot draw image image to draw as
background
it wants a float rectangle so get local
bounce
to float all right let's take a look
all right cool it looks like something
good times
um so for this graphic stuff we're going
to switch to the standalone plugin
so that way um we don't need to deal
with audio plug and host at the moment
we're just
looking at graphics changes let's look
at that one more time
okay so the first problem is that
there's a lot of collision happening
like our plus 24 line and our negative
24 line
uh we don't even see them so we need to
shrink the bounding box that we are
using
to compute these values within which
means we also need to adjust how our
path
is going to get produced so let's go to
our
editor editor.h
and then below this let's add a function
that will give us the area we will draw
our background grid in and also our
response curve in
i'm going to call mine get render area
it's going to return a
juice rectangle
now go to our plugin editor.cpp and
let's go to the bot um go to the bottom
of that
after the resized function
all right so let's use some juice live
constant to figure out the
bounding box of this all we know is that
we are going to reduce our local
bounding box but
not by how much so this will be a good
chance to figure that out
so
we're going to use the reduce function
i'm going to reduce it by
some amount we'll do
start with five i'm going to reduce both
the x
and the y and it's important to make
sure you put juice live constant on its
own line
one instance per line
okay for right now we're going to stop
drawing the vertical lines
as well as the horizontal lines
and we're just going to draw the render
area
okay so let's run this and let's dial in
the values here
let's move this out of the way okay so
if we increase this
we shrink it we shrink the width
and then if we do this one we shrink the
height okay so let's figure out what
looks good
i know i'm going to want to have some
text on this side
and on this side showing like the actual
values for the lines
like you know 0 db plus 24 and minus 24
and then whatever i'm going to come up
with here and then we need our
frequencies
uh to get displayed either above or
below
somewhere so let's dial this in
all right and i like shrinking it by 10
i think this is a good width and then
height wise i don't think i need that
much
i'm going to go with 8. so 10
for the width reduction and then 8 for
the
height reduction 10 and 8.
so let me just make that change here 10
8
put this on its own line for right now
okay i'm happy with that so let's make
the response curve sit within
this rectangle now all right let's go to
our paint function
now all we have to do is change this
line right here
response area is going to be get
render area auto response area equals
get
render area talk about easy i am glad we
planned ahead on that by using this
response area to represent what we are
drawing let's take a look
okay cool so this is being drawn inside
here it's also
we're getting a little bit of the path
being drawn outside of it because
our response area is um
is smaller than our component and this
path is being drawn inside
you know the entire component so we'll
figure that out in a little bit but
this is cool all right we're making
progress
now i'm going to change this from being
reduced on all sides to
being reduced mainly on the top and the
sides we want to leave room for the
frequency label on the top
and the db levels on the sides but for
the bottom i don't really care about
that so
uh we're going to get rid of that we're
going to do bounce dot remove from top
we're going to give us a gap of 12 at
the top
from the bottom we're just going to do a
little gap maybe something like that and
then on the sides
um my i think we need more than 10
so we'll do 20 pounds.remove from left
20 and then bounce.remove from right
20. all right let's take a look at that
okay cool so we've got two pixels of
space here
we got our 20 here this is plenty of
room to have small text
and then same for on the top we can put
some uh low height
um yeah like use a font that's not very
tall for right there
okay so let's go um let's separate the
render area from the actual analysis
area
so let's add another function here
and it's going to be called get analysis
area and that's actually going to be
what we draw the response curve within
so if i pull this back up
when we see our you'll have to just
imagine the grid lines for right now
but just imagine that like we're not
going to have the plus 24 be underneath
this like right at this orange line it's
going to be slightly less than it
and same for the bottom our negative 24
is not going to be on this orange line
it's going to be slightly above it
so that's what i mean when i say our
analysis area is going to be a little
bit
smaller than our render area
all right so let's implement this back
to our cpp file put this right here
all right we're going to start with our
render area
and then we're going to trim some off
the top and trim off the bottom
so that way we can see the um the top
and bottom line of our
um grid as i had explained as i had
explained a moment ago balance dot
remove from top a gap of four should be
nice
bounce down remove from bottom same size
gap
all right now let's use this instead of
the response area
in our paint function so
response area uh not get local bounds
or not get render area let's use get
analysis area
all right so let's take a look at that
okay all right so we're still we're
seeing our orange rectangle in the wrong
uh wrong spot so let's take care of that
that goes down here
um that's at the bottom that's this guy
right here so instead of using the
response area we want to use the render
area
okay cool all right so
now let's go back to our
um our resized function
and let's draw our analysis area
right yes let's display our analysis
area
so we have an idea of where this
actually is
all right cool so yes um it's slightly
in
slightly set inside our um orange
uh render area
okay so let's see let's go up to our
frequencies
we want to be drawing inside of this
analysis area instead of the local bound
so let's cache
some information about this analysis
area let's do this right here we'll go
to auto render
area equals get analysis area and now
let's cache the left
right top bottom and width
okay because we need the left and the
right for our horizontal lines we need
the
the top and the bottom for our vertical
lines
um and then we also need the width for
um
uh is it this thing um well either way
all right let's just start caching them
auto left equals
since the frequency labels as well as
the vertical lines we'll need this
x position let's just um cache this
value into an array
all right so we're going to use the same
mapping code where we convert our
frequency value to a a normalized
position
and then just compute that to a
a window x position um based off of this
left edge of our render area
all right now we can actually draw our
vertical lines let's get rid of this
i'm going to use uh i'm not going to use
white i'm going to use dim gray for this
so instead of looping through our
frequencies
let's loop through our x positions
and we don't need this line anymore
instead we need uh this right here
we're going to draw x and from the top
to the bottom
all right now let's go to our gain and
let's see we can make it
instead of using our get height and zero
we can use our bottom
and top okay and then
uh i want to make the zero db line
um have the same color as our min and
max slider labels and everything else is
going to be grace that will be
it'll you know we'll be able to visually
see where is zero
so we will do g dot set color
if it's zero then we're gonna use that
one color otherwise we're gonna use um a
darker color
it could you know dark gray is cool all
right let's go find that green color
that's in our slider
where is that order slider paint uh this
color right here
and this should probably be standardized
into a
static color at some point you know
define it at the top of the header file
but for right now this is good enough
all right so we're going to use that
right there
all right and we don't need this border
anymore so let's run it and take a look
oh i forgot to uh draw the line so g dot
draw horizontal line uh at y
and then left right
so we should see a green line in the
center and there we go
awesome it's looking good
okay so the next thing to do is to draw
the frequency labels
let's make a little commit of what we've
done so far
right we basically roughed out the grid
lines added
grid lines
added grid lines um into
so uh let's see we actually um we added
grid lines we also um pre-rendered
grid into background image
cool okay so frequency labels let's draw
these down here
get rid of that line we'll do a clean up
at the end okay so i want to draw these
with that light gray color
so that way they pop out a little bit so
let's set our color there
we want to use a font height of 10. if
you remember our
um our render area we gave ourselves a
room of
12 between the top of our component and
where our render area
is so i'm going to draw inside that
little 12
gap so that's why i'm going to use a
font height of 10.
if i need to tweak that i can tweak it
later all right so now
what we will do is loop through our
frequencies and x's and draw the text
above the grid at those particular
positions
now i'm gonna use the same trick um that
i used when drawing the
uh labels uh for the min and the max
range where i
um added kilohertz
use that same trick right here
all right then we can just assemble our
string
lowercase
all right and we're gonna do the same
trick that we used with the string width
and building a rectangle around it
very simple stuff we've got a rectangle
we're going to give it a particular size
i know where i want the center x but not
the y
and that's okay because i can set the y
after i have already set
the x position all right all we need to
do now is just draw
our text
all right let's run it and take a look
all right cool uh we got some collision
of text going on here
that's okay though figure that out next
all right so it looks like the 40
and the 30 and the 40 are getting pretty
close 300 and 400
collide a lot 3k and 4k collide a lot so
let's get rid of those
and let's try that again ah much
cleaners
these are much easier to see now that
they're not colliding on each other
cool all right so let's add a commit for
that added frequency labels
and we also thinned out
number of frequencies
all right let's do the gain labels next
all right let's go to where we are
looping through our gain labels
that right here so we're actually going
to do this down here
all right we're going to loop through
our gain labels the exact same way we're
going to need that y value
all right now we need to make a string
with the gain value if it's greater than
0 i want to see a plus sign
if it's and if it's not it's going to be
a negative number so let's do the same
thing string str
if gdb
is greater than zero uh add the plus
sign
and then just feed in that gain value
all right let's get the width like we
did before and then we're going to build
a bounding box around that
just like we did before same thing here
okay now we're going to draw these on
the right side of the screen so our x
position
is going to be the width get width
minus our text width and then our height
is going to be um
uh let's see we're going to i'm not sure
where i want the y position to be but i
do know that i want the center of this
rectangle
to be lined up with this so i'm going to
use the
r dot set center use this
thing i know i wanted to use the current
center x
and i know i want um this to be y
okay so like i said i know where i want
the
left edge of this to be i don't know
where i want the um
y position to be but i do know that i
want the um
the center of this text to be at this y
position which is the same position we
are drawing our gain
lines so i can do that same trick where
i've got um
i know the x um the rectangle has the
current x position so i can
get the center x of the rectangle and
then i can set the y
i can set the center with this y value
okay now let's just set our color i want
to do the same
trick i used here where i set it to
green if the line
should be green the only difference is
i'm going to um
i'm going to draw the text as light gray
to match
the other color i used for this
text all right so this is going to give
me
a greenish text color for the 0db
mark and then now
we just need to draw our text
it's this thing right here all right
let's take a look at that
all right cool we got plus 24 plus 12 0
in green
uh minus 24 minus 12. awesome
all right let's make a little note about
that added
uh gain labels
to grid
okay let's add another scale let me pull
this up on this side
since we are going to be doing an
analyzer let's add another scale on this
side
for that okay now our gain range for the
peak band was
uh 48 you know we could do from plus 24
to -24 so let's do the same for the
analyzer
we'll do 0 to negative 48. so this is
easy all we have to do is subtract
24 from the decibel value
just do that right here we can go
str.clear
clear out our string um let's fill it in
again this way
since we we're not going to have any
values over zero we don't need to worry
about that
so we can just do g db minus
24. right now
uh let's just adjust the text bounding
box like we did before
so we know our x position is going to be
on the far left
not on the actual left but like one
pixel off from it so r dot set x
one uh we need to recompute our string
width
then we need to set our size accordingly
then
um we can set our color to just always
be light gray
that was written up here
then let's just draw our fitted text
inside this rectangle all right so
that's good times all we are changing is
the x position
and then the actual size of it all right
let's take a look
all right cool we got our 0 minus 12
minus 24
minus 36 minus 48. cool
all right so that takes care of that
background grid
let's do a little cleanup
and then um yeah do that clean up
let's take a quick look through all this
stuff
here we go get rid of that line get rid
of this
okay that takes care of those guys so
what we're gonna do next
is the fft analyzer and then the bypass
buttons
okay let's um commit that
what we added here this is a code
cleanup
and then we also added analyzer decibel
marks
added analyzer decibel
marks cleaned up code awesome
all right let's head on over to
pluginprocessor.h
okay go up to the top now our analyzer
will
display two fft curves one for each
audio channel
that's because the fft algorithm
operates on a
single channel of audio okay
uh we are going to express that
programmatically
all right this is uh effectively
zero effectively one
okay now the fft operates the fft
algorithm operates on a
fixed number of samples the host is
passing in buffers which can have a
variety of different sizes so we need a
way to collect them into blocks
of fixed sizes that's what this class
does
that's what this class right here does
i'll zoom out a little bit i'm not going
to explain how it works
right if you want to know how this class
works or how to make it
you can check it out in my uh pfm
project 11 course where i
explain how to make every little part of
this and how to get it all to work
together
okay let me zoom back in
next while our single sample fifo is
collecting individual samples
from the buffers into blocks we need a
fifo that the gui thread can use to
retrieve these blocks
that this single channel sample fifo has
produced
that's what this class does that's what
this class right here does
all right if you want to know how to
make this or how to write it you can
learn
how this gets put together in my course
pfm c-plus plus for musicians
all right you can check those guys out
links in the description and all that
good stuff okay
let's go to the next part all right we
need some instances of these things so
let's go to our class down here
now we're going to need one instance of
this single channel fifo per
audio channel remember we are working on
stereo buffers
because it is a templated class i'm
going to create a type alias to the type
that we will be passing
into it so we don't have to type so much
okay these also need to be public
because the gui is going to need to
access them okay we are going to need
pointers to this class in the gui side
of things
and this alias will make it easier to
declare
instances to declare pointer instances
of that single channel sample fifo so
let's do that now
and then let's declare our instances
all right the single channel fifos need
to be prepared so let's go do that in
our plug-in processor
prepare to play a lot of pete words
right there
prepare to play go to the bottom of it
after our filters this is where we're
going to prepare our fifos
left channel fifo dot prepare
samples per block same thing for the
right side
okay now we just need to push buffers
into it so go to the process block
and at the very end after our processing
is done
we're going to update it with our buffer
same for the right side okay let's go to
our plugin editor dot h
and we're going to go to our uh response
curve component
the bottom of it we are going to convert
some audio samples into fft data
this is not going to be simple okay we
are basically going to build
um this system let's see i have this
kind of drawn out
on this grid i'll let me make it bigger
because it's important to know what's
going on
okay we are basically going to build
this system right here
so here's what happens the audio buffers
from the host go into the
single channel sample fifo right here
okay the single channel uh single
channel sample fifo spits out
fixed size blocks okay
then these fixed size blocks go into an
fft data generator
right and this thing spits out fft data
blocks
the fft data blocks go into a path
producer right here and then the path
producer spits out juice
path instances and finally the gui
consumes those
and renders the paths okay so
buffers of random size are fed into the
single channel sample fifo right here
this thing spits out fixed
size blocks then those go into an fft
data generator
the fft data generator spits out fft
data blocks
then those get run through a path
producer which produces juice
paths and those get rendered and
consumed by the gui
okay that's what we're gonna build okay
so let's give ourselves a pointer to one
of the audio processors single channel
sample fifos single
channel sample fifo uh it's that block
type
simple eq audio processor
block type this is gonna and we're doing
a pointer to it
left channel fifo we're just gonna do
the left side for right now
let's go to our cpp file let's go to our
uh response curve constructor
and we need to initialize this guy let's
put this on its own line
um this is where we're going to do left
channel fifo and we want to pass it the
audio processor dot what's the name of
that thing the left channel fifo
okay let's go to our timer callback
now this is where we are going to
coordinate all of those pieces of the
system
let me pull this back up we are going to
coordinate
um coordinate this thing
with this with this and with this okay
we're gonna coordinate all those little
parts together
first thing we're gonna do is the single
channel
uh sample fifo so here's the logic we
are going to use
while there are buffers to pull if we
can pull a buffer we're going to send it
to the fft
data generator so the first thing we
need is a temp buffer to pull into
okay we're going to do this um before
all of this uh parameters change stuff
okay let's make our temporary buffer
all right uh just before we do that
actually let me go through and just
clarify the interface
um for our fifo guy single channel
sample fifo all we need care about is
like
uh how do we feed it buffers how do we
prepare it and how do we get
buffers from it okay this is how we know
how many we have and this is how we
actually get a buffer from it
okay very simple to use same thing for
this fifo right here
we just push stuff into it and pull
stuff out of it
and make sure that we've prepared it
with however much
pre-allocated space we need okay
all right so we need to um go through
this logic again
you know while there are buffers to pull
from the single channel sample fifo
if we can pull it then we're going to
send it to the fft data generator
all right so let's add our while loop
while left channel fifo
get num buffers available if that's
greater than zero
there are more than zero buffers
available to be pulled
let's try to pull one get
give me that audio buffer temp incoming
buffer
if we can pull one of these then we are
going to send it to the fft data
generator
all right now it is very important that
we maintain the order of the blocks
coming in from the audio thread
so before we send audio samples to the
fft data generator which we have not
written yet
we have to make sure that they stay in
the same order okay we also need to make
sure that the blocks being sent to the
ffd
uh data generator is the right size so
let's create a mono buffer first for
that
all right let's go over to our header
file put this right here
so this is what we are this is what the
buffer we are going to create now is
what we will be ferrying
blocks of audio from right to left
through
so um let me see let me just draw a
quick graph of what i'm talking about
here
okay so what i was saying about how the
buffers need to be ferried from the
right side to the left
so this is an example of like of
waveform you know t
equals zero and then all the way to the
end of it okay so what happens is
the buffers are passed to us from the
host and they you know
that's what these a b and c blocks are
so what happens is we're given a and
then
we need to basically when we consume
things with our fft and our um
single channel sample fifo we're
basically taking one of these blocks and
then running it through that
chain that i showed before and then the
whole thing needs to shift over
uh this direction okay so the a block
gets discarded
right it was just consumed by the gui
and then what was in
block b and c they get shifted over like
this so you can see the continuity
of this point right here to this point
right there same for that point right
there in that point there
here's the new data from the host it's
getting um
added to the waveform right here so it's
all continuous
and that gets now we consume this part
right here okay then the same thing
happens this little chunk of audio gets
run through the fft
stuff and produce is turned into a path
and then that gets
consumed and then the whole thing gets
shifted over again so that's why
you can see that this piece gets shifted
to block number two then it gets shifted
to block number one and then it gets
consumed okay so that's what i meant
about how we have to append
uh the blocks um to the end of it and
shift everything
uh towards the front of the vector
okay so we're going to implement that
now okay
so uh we are going to need a uh
we're going to need a monobuffer because
remember these are mono channels of
audio
um newest blocks are going to get stuck
at the end and the oldest blocks are
going to go at the front so that way
everything gets kind of you know
shifted over this way okay step
14. all right let's go back to our cpp
file now that we have declared a mono
buffer
all right first we are going to shift
everything in the mono buffer
forward by however many samples there
are in that temporary incoming buffer
okay so let's get our size first
all right now let's do the copy
okay so we are copying
everything from this point which is
size samples across let me pull this
picture back up
okay so let's pretend that this is our
monobuffer right here it contains this
waveform in terms of samples
okay our new chunk of data um is going
to get appended here so what we need to
do is
basically copy all these samples
starting at position b
shift them over by however much this is
this direction so that's what we do here
first we get uh
we're going to copy everything to the
zero with uh index right there
and then we're gonna start reading from
this point which is b
okay that's what this thing does that's
our index size
that's our index um right there and then
we're gonna read
uh this many samples so if our buffer is
holding this long and we are going to
read uh
this many samples from it that's how
much we have to shift over so
we need to keep this much okay i didn't
explain that very well but
you can see from the code here what's
happening so once we have done that now
we can copy
our temp buffer uh copy all the samples
from that to the end of our mono buffer
so our size we're going to copy that
many samples
put this on its own line our source is
going to be the temp incoming buffer
um it's going to be the zeroth channel
zero with index and we're going to copy
it
to our monobuffer get right pointer
copying it to the zeros channel and our
sample index
is going to be this position okay if
this doesn't make much sense to you
i suggest that you get out a a line
graph
uh draw a number line and then
you know just like manually draw a block
of data moving from one part
to earlier in the chain to earlier in
the chain and data being added after it
and use varying sizes so you can see how
what we how far we have it have to move
it backwards
uh sorry how far we have to move it
towards the front
is dependent upon what size of our block
that is coming in
is okay so that takes care of those
things all right
we're shifting over the data and then
we're copying this to the end
and the good thing um about this is that
um the monobuffer never actually changes
size
so the next thing to do is to write the
fft data generator
however if you remember what i said
earlier the fft
requires a specific number of samples in
order to do its processing so we must
make the monobuffer
have that same size and this is good
because we don't know how big to make
the monobuffer
for us to be able to copy into it and to
move samples around it
like at this point based on our current
code this is not going to work it's
going to explode because the monobuffer
doesn't have any channels and it doesn't
have any samples
so we're going to try to do like a
negative we're going to copy like
negative samples and it's just going to
explode okay
so once the fft data generator is built
we will know
what size to use for the monobuffer so
we're going to do that next
once we are done with those two things
then we can start sending buffers
from uh the we can start sending mono
buffers into the fft data
generator okay so let's make this next
all right this is going to go up here
all right this is the fft data
generator all right let's take a quick
glance at it
it's got a lot of good stuff in it it's
pretty it's a pretty
complicated piece of uh software
machinery
now if you want to know how to build it
yourself i go through the entire process
from scratch
in the pfm project 11 course all we need
to know
for our purposes is how do we feed it
audio
how do we get fft data out of it and
then how do we configure it
okay so let's do the configuration first
uh configuration depends on this stuff
right here
here's how we feed audio into it
and then here's how we get our fft data
and here's how we
see how much ffdata fft data we have
available to us okay
that's the basic interface all right
let's give ourselves an instance of this
after our monobuffer all right now the
fft data generator
operates on vectors of floats not audio
buffers
okay let's go to our constructor
so we can initialize this thing okay go
to our response curve constructor
okay we're going to do this before we
start updating our chain all right let's
use an order of
2048 that'll give us some really nice
resolution
in the uh uh that'll give us average
resolution
um in the uh lower end of the spectrum
okay we're basically going to be
splitting the audio spectrum up into
uh 2048 or 4096.
basically whatever value we pick from
here okay we can do 2848
4096 8192 basically what we are doing is
splitting up the audio
spectrum from 20 hertz to 20 000 hertz
into
2048 equally sized frequency bins now
these bins
store the magnitude level for a
particular range of frequencies
i'm not going to get into the math
behind this but here's the simple
summation
okay if we have 2048 bins and a sample
rate is
48 000 then each bin represents roughly
23 hertz in our spectrum okay so that's
very simple math if our sample rate is
48 000
and then we have 2048 bins each bin
roughly accounts for 23 hertz so that
means
we're going to let this means we're
gonna get a lot of resolution at the
upper end
and not a lot of resolution at the
bottom end so let's
just take a look um at our plot so you
can see what i'm talking about okay you
can see that like
whoops yeah this is what i meant about
how it doesn't um
let me comment out that code this stuff
right here let's comment this out so
this is what i meant how like if each
bin
represents 23 hertz between 20 and 50
between this part of the display and
this part of the display
you know 20 plus 23 is 43 so
that's how big one bin is way down here
okay
but way up here we've got 2 000 to 5
000. how many bins are there
let's find out so 5 thousand minus two
thousand
okay divided by oops divided by 23.
there's a hundred and thirty bins that
are in between here
so we're going to get a lot of
resolution
uh way up here but not a lot of
resolution down here
okay this is the big problem with fft
but it's you know
it's just that's just how it works okay
so the lowest five percent of this fee
of the
frequency spectrum is going to represent
50 percent of the display and the
remaining 95 percent
is going to represent the other
um yeah and it's going to represent the
other
uh 50 what is that referring to i am
referring to
where we've got one kilohertz is 50 of
the display from zero to one kilohertz
and our
range is 20 kilohertz so that means this
is 120th
from right here to right here we cover
five percent of our frequency range
and then this part the other half of the
display is covering the remaining 95
percent
okay so all this is saying that you know
um
our we're going to get a ton of
resolution here um
not a lot of resolution here the only
ways to
improve that is to increase the fft
order
when you do that the fft ends up
needing more and more cpu so there's a
nice balance between
2048 versus 4096
versus 8192 in terms of these
the order that the fft is configured in
okay um that was kind of confusing but
basically
when you make the order higher you get
more resolution in the lower end at the
expense of
more cpu okay so we're gonna put it at
2048
uh frequency bins for right now just so
that way
we don't have major performance impacts
when we actually use this thing let's
turn this back on
let's go back to our constructor and now
we're going to configure this
left channel fifo left channel fft data
generator dot
change order and we're going to use fft
order oops fft
order and 2048. all right now that our
fft data generator has been configured
we can initialize the monobuffer with
the proper
size so we can do monobuffer dot set
size
we are processing one channel and our
number of samples
is whatever size this thing needs
left get fft size we can uncomment these
guys these guys are uncommented
all right now that we have this and the
monobuffer is set up and the fft data
generator is ready to receive buffers we
can start sending
mono buffers to the generator so we can
do
left channel fft data generator dot
produce
some fft data we're going to pass it the
mono buffer
and we want to use negative infinity
we want to use our negative 48 as where
negative infinity is or we can change
this value later
okay so let's check this out i'll just
put negative 48 because i want the
bottom of my display
bottom of my spectrum analyzer that grid
point
um i had set the scale to negative 48 so
i'm going to use that right now for
the concept of negative infinity okay so
let's build it and see what happens
all right build failed why are we
failing too few arguments
expect to call aha this is because our
fifo class needs a second prepare
function to
handle when the type is vector not audio
buffer
that's over here in our plug-in
processor all right it wants this
we are currently using this let's see
what's going on prepares declared here
we are instantiating it um where is this
being called from
it's being called right here where we've
got an uh fifo
uh with our block type of um
where was this declared this was being
declared with uh std vector
okay so that means this fifo has a block
type
of std vector okay and so obviously
std vector does not have a set size
function so we need to
create a new prepare function all right
let's go do that
all right let's use some static asserts
to remind us if we are using
to remind us which prepare function to
use so we'll do static
assert our expression is going to be std
is same there it is all right
if um our template type is t
um we want to only use this prepare
function
if our t is audio buffer
so prepare num samples
okay it's helpful helping ourselves
so check it out if we build it now
static assert failed
so that's fantastic failed to meet
requirement
and then we can see the message it
should only use one fifo
okay that's good times and it says right
here uh
instantiation of member std uh fifo std
vector
okay so we can you know help ourselves
out that way
let's write the other uh prepare
function void prepare
and this is gonna be size t num elements
because
vector uses size t internally we'll do
the same
static assert we'll change the message a
bit
instead of this we will use std
vector and this should be num elements
num elements should only be used when
the fifo is holding
std vector float all right let's uh loop
through this
here we're gonna go for auto buffer
buffers buffer uh let's see
dot clear clear at first then buffer dot
resize
num elements and fill it with zeros
all right now let's build it all right
build succeeded
let's head on over to plugineditor.cpp
now the fft data generator let's go down
to our timer callback
okay the fft data generator is producing
fft data blocks for us
so now we need to turn those blocks into
a path
instance okay so let's write a path
generator class
all right let's go up to our header file
we'll go after the
fft data generator before the look and
feel guy
now this class is going to take in this
fft data
a bounding box info about the fft size
and the bin width and it's going to spit
out a path okay
now this is the this is a simplified
version of the path producer in
project 11 so if you want to learn how
to make the advanced version
check out the course you're going to
learn to make all this stuff from
scratch
by yourself i'm going to give you the
instructions and then review your code
which is pretty cool all right let's do
this
all right i'm just going to paste it
right here okay we can check this out in
just a little bit
okay all we need to know is how to feed
it
our data via the generatepath function
and then how to get
paths out of it that's what this does
right here
okay so we've got our number available
we've got our
uh our function that gives us any paths
that we request
and then here's how it actually converts
that into data so again if you want to
learn how to actually write this from
scratch
and learn how it actually works this is
a simplified version of the big one
in the full course okay all right
obviously we are going to need an
instance so let's give ourselves one of
those
that goes down here analyzer
path generator we want to feed it
juice paths or we want it to produce
juice
paths for us path producer
now we can go back to our timer callback
and use our
familiar logic while there are fft
data buffers to pull if we can pull a
buffer
let's generate a path okay so i'll just
make a little comment myself
if there are fft data buffers
to pull if we can pull a buffer
generate a path all right very simple
okay now the path producer will produce
a path inside of whatever bounding box
we give it
okay let's just take a look at this
interface real quick all right so we've
got
it wants some rendered data it's going
to want a bounding box and it wants to
know the fft size
the bin width and where negative
infinity is
or what value is being considered
negative infinity
okay so let's provide those things
so our bounding box is going to be our
fft bounds get analysis area
and it wants it to be to float all right
and it needs to know the fft
size and the bin width and frequencies
so
the fft size as we showed in the
constructor
we can just get it right from the
constructor like that or right from that
uh
fft generator class auto fft
size oh these should be const because
they're not going to change
okay and then we need to know our bin
width
and that's going to be as we showed up
here our sample rate divided by our
fft size let me just copy this down here
bin width all right
so const auto bin width equals
audio processor i'll get the sample rate
divide that by our fft size convert it
to double because
sample rate is a double okay
now we can implement our logic here
while
left channel f50 data generator
um while it has fft blocks whoops
right if it has more than zero blocks
available
let's try to get one okay we need a
temporary vector
std vector float uh fft data
put past that here all right if we're
able to pull one
then we can pass our vector of
fft data to our fft data
to our path producer sorry okay one more
time
so we're going to check if we have more
than zero
fft blocks available good
um if we if there are more than zero fft
blocks available let's try to pull one
and if we are able to pull one this
vector now contains our fft data which
we can then
feed to our paths producer okay
so let's pass that along fft data we
know our bounds that's that fft bounds
we know our fft size we know our bin
width
and we'll use that negative 48 again for
the
concept of negative infinity all right
that should build without errors
all right good times i'll let you see
this uh
fft this path generator one more time so
you can
try to copy the code real quickly scroll
down a little bit you can just pause the
video if you need to to see it
good times same for this one right here
all right
there's the path there's the data
generator
okay all right so this builds currently
um we are almost there we just need to
retrieve these paths
and then draw them all right go to your
plugin editor dot h
okay go down to after where we added our
path producer
all right we have at this point we are
producing paths in our path generator
now we just need a path to draw and to
pull into okay
because remember we're pulling it from
the timer callback we need to get it
into our paint function
so it needs to be a member variable
choose path
left channel fft path okay
that's makes sense why we have that
all right let's go to our plugin editor
back to our timer callback
so at this point a path producer has
potentially created a path for us
so we need to try to pull them
now what happens if we are producing
paths
faster than we can consume them we just
want the most recent one so our logic is
going to be
while there are paths that can be pulled
pull as many as we can because we only
we're only going to display the most
recent path
all right so while uh
path producer get num paths available
now we can do path producer
get path and we can use our left channel
fft data path okay
that has successfully pulled that path
now
previously we were only repainting
whenever the um
parameters were changed but because
we're pulling paths all the time
we need to repaint all the time so this
gets commented out
this goes here repaint like that
all right now we just need to paint the
actual path
let's go here all right let's go to our
timer
let's go to our paint function and let's
draw this
where are we going to draw this let's
draw this before we draw our
uh where is this let's draw this before
we draw our rendered area so it's behind
everything
okay let's do let's i'm going to use a
blue color
all right and we can just do g stroke
path
left channel fft data fft path and then
i'm just going to use a path stroke type
of
with a thickness of one and let's run it
we should see something oh my fault what
is going on here i spelled that wrong i
did spell that wrong okay let's run this
um not as the standalone but as the
plugin
has the plugin in the audio plugin host
okay we should see something
once we actually press play okay
all right we have a blue line what
happens if we actually run audio through
this
all right it's doing something
[Applause]
okay cool that is an fft that is a
spectrum analysis
okay now it's in the wrong place but it
is working
which is awesome so we can fix that
positioning next
let's make a commit of that because that
was a lot all right uh
implemented basic fft
um design
okay of course in the description i will
have
um you can the links in
the links in the description the links
in the description
will um there will be a link to this
repository so you can check out the code
for yourself
um uh once this video is out
and then you can get the code for the
single channel sample fifo the fft data
generator and the analyzer path
generator
okay all right now there's a small bug
right here
with the way this stuff is getting
mapped we are currently mapping from
um we're mapping our bin frequency from
1 to 20 hertz but our frequency range is
not 1 to 20 hertz it's
20 to 20 hertz so that's the first bug
fix we need to do
okay if we run this and check it out it
should look a little bit different
or the x positions should look a little
bit different
okay now it's hard to tell but basically
we weren't seeing a lot of left
stuff on the left side okay so that's a
good time
all right let's close that let's save
this so our parameters are saved
and we if we want we can use a different
color to make the paths more
visible it's you know that blue color is
kind of hard to see
okay let's start making this show up in
the right spot
okay let's go to our paint function okay
now when the path generator creates a
path
it does not take into account the origin
of the rectangle that defines
the bounding box so we need to translate
our path
to the analysis bounding boxes origin
okay right now this path is drawn at
zero
comma 0 and we need it to be drawn at um
our response areas x and y that needs to
be the left side of the path okay
so we need to do a translate first so
let's do that right here
left channel fft path dot
apply transform so we're going to do a
normal a fine transform and we're going
to add a translation to it
so we want to do response area dot get x
and response area dot get y
okay what does that do if we run it
that should be all we need to do okay
cool this is like
right the right on the negative 48 so
let's push play
cool so it's now drawing in the right
spot i'm gonna use a different
use like sky blue or something for this
instead of that dark blue
so we can see it a little bit better oh
what happened here oh there's a bug for
that
that's right it's gonna do that for a
while for some reason
um we'll figure it out the fft data is
just full of
nands i'll just comment that out for
right now
okay let's press play all right that's
easier to see
that's all i'm trying to show
[Applause]
okay cool all right we'll figure that
out in a little bit
all right let's make a commit showing um
that we fixed the positioning
because sometimes those types of bugs
will take a long time
to diagnose and then solve okay so
fixed fft path position
stage that stage that stage that
okay next we need to verify the accuracy
of the analyzer
now to do this we are going to go to our
pluginprocessor.h
we are going to well we're going to
switch to the standalone version
and then we are going to we're going to
use an oscillator to do this
and we need to initialize it prepare it
and then use it in the process block
so we're going to feed it a test signal
go way down here
right down to the bottom after our
update filters so juice
dsp oscillator float
like that okay that is now declared
we're going to
make this produce a sine wave at a
particular frequency and we want it to
line up with our
we want it to line up on our grid where
it should
okay so let's go to our um where do we
go next
we go we need to prepare it so let's go
to our prepare to play function
let's do this at the end uh the
oscillator wants a function
that returns a value when you feed it a
radian angle
okay so std sine wrapped in a lambda
will do that for us so
oscillator dot initialize here it wants
um
uh lambda that takes in a number and
returns a number
so let's do that here's our number that
it's going to take
and then here's what it's going to
return
okay now we need to prepare it and we
can use the same spec for our chain as
long as we just change
the number of channels okay previously
we were given
um we were saying our spec only had one
channel we just need to change that
spec.num channels equals get total
num output channels sure
and then we can prepare it ask.prepair
the spec then let's give it a frequency
of 200
because that's one of our points in the
grid ask.set frequency we'll be changing
that frequency
for a while just to verify the accuracy
so i'm going to go with uh
uh that value 200 initially
and let's see what comes next
all right let's go to our prepare our
process block because we want to
use our oscillator to fill the buffer
okay so we're going to do this before
we um we're going to do this after our
filters
are configured but before we actually
run the sound through
the filters we don't want to hear any of
the audio that's currently coming in
so we'll do buffer.clear
and then we need to make a stereo
context and then give it to our
oscillator to process
that's all we have to do so let's see
this block is already stereo
so let's see i'm going to
move this after this thing
okay buffer's clear we need let's make
our stereo context for this block
stereo context from the block and then
now we can just do
ask.process stereo
context all right that's it okay and we
can now check the accuracy
so apologies in advance for the annoying
sine waves we're going to hear
okay so our frequency was 200 so let's
try 500 and 1050 and
5k and see what it looks like so i'm
going to change this to
a thousand we should see a little blip
right at that point
all right that's good for me thousand
let's do the annoying one
five thousand
yep right at 5k yikes that's painful
let's make this 50. this will be the
last one that we test
all right i'm not seeing anything at 50
so let's try 100.
all right there's our 100 okay so 50 was
pretty low for some reason it's pretty
accurate
it you know it's showing a peak at 100
it showed a peak at 200
1k 5k okay so
that's good times um if we want to do
more resolution in the lower end we
could just change the order
of the fft generator but this is good
enough for this project you know like
we're just trying to get our feet wet
and understand how some of these
uh things get put together in audio
plugins
so the next thing to do is to add a
second set of generators that can
produce a path
for the right audio channel all right
let's get rid of our
let's get rid of that process block
stuff
this stuff right here let's just comment
that out in case you know we're gonna
leave the code in in case we ever need
to
test that again but
that's you know we're going to turn that
off because
who wants to listen to those sine waves
again
okay let's grab everything we used in
the single channel version of the fft
and put it into its own class this is
going to be the
single channel fifo buffer the
monobuffer fft generator
analyzer path generator and the path
itself
so let's make a new class we're just
going to migrate these things over there
first okay so i'm just going to
cut these we're going to go up here
we're going to put it right here
put them right there all right so we
have moved those over
okay this is going to produce a ton of
errors if we try to build it right now
but we will get to that
now we just need to give our response
curve a path producer for both channels
okay next we need to add a process
function that's going to basically do
what the
timer callback did
let's jump to that so we can kind of get
a feel of what i'm talking about
um this process function is going to do
this it's going to do
this stuff and it's going to do this
thing okay
so let's declare that first
um actually let's take a look at this so
let's see right now
um the only things we actually need from
it are
uh this temp buffer uh fft bounds and
fft size
and bin width um yeah okay so we just
need
and even then like this this fft size
comes from this member variable
um fft bounds that's just a rectangle we
can provide that
and then um we need the sample rate
okay so let's do that let's go back here
let's declare this
let's make these guys private private
void process let's give it our rectangle
and the sample rate okay
now we need a way to retrieve the path
so let's add that okay
all right now we need to do what the
response curve constructor did to
initialize the fft
data generator and um
the monobuffer so let's add a
constructor
all right let's go out of constructor
let's do it in class for right now
it's gonna take this same um
this same argument
s c s f and let's initialize that
left channel fifo scff
scsf okay now let's just migrate over
that code from the constructor
over here where was that that's this
thing okay we're gonna just
grab these two lines cut them
paste them here all right now we just
need to initialize
our um path producers from our
response curve so let's get rid of this
line and now we can do path
left path producer and this is where we
need the audio processor
left channel fifo address of that
or not the address it wants a reference
and then
right channel path producer this one's
the audio processor
right channel fifo all right let's
implement this
um path producer process function
let's put that right above our um
right above this actually let's just put
it right above this timer callback
because
it'll make copying the code easier so
void we can move it later
path producer process
okay so we need our temp buffer these
guys just go like that copy and paste it
do the same thing with the fft bounds
and
through the path producer loops
and now instead of doing auto fft equals
get analysis area this is a function
argument
so let's get rid of that and then our
bin with is
using the sample rate very convenient
all right so we took all of that code
away
and now we are going to call our process
function
instead auto fft bounds
equals get analysis area dot to float
and then auto sample rate equals
audio processor dot get sample rate
and then we can do left path producer
fft dot process fft bounds
sample rate and then right path
producer process fft bounce
sample rate now we just need to grab the
paths returned from this
in our paint function and draw them so
let's go up to our paint function
go to where those paths are drawn it's
right here
uh we will do auto left path fft
sorry left channel fft path fft path
equals leftpathproducer.getpath
okay that takes care of that and then we
can also
uh let's see we're doing sky blue for
that that's cool and now we can do the
same thing with the right path
auto right channel fft
path equals right channel uh
get path and do the same transform
and then draw it the same way
i'm going to do yellow for this guy
i'll do a light yellow all right let's
test it out
we should be able to see two analyzer
paths
ah actually this is the standalone
version so
let me quit this and then run
the vst version and now we can run some
audio through it
and it should be good to go okay let's
press play we should hear some audio
all right cool all right cool so i'm i'm
so i'm i'm not
seeing that so the solution well i'm
seeing a yellow i'm seeing a yellow path
um i guess our file is our file is this
file that uses file that i'm using is
uh fairly
[Music]
[Music]
why is that only doing that
[Music]
interesting interesting we're not seeing
we're not writing our right channel for
some reason
all right let's see if we can figure
let's see if we can figure that out
i found the error so the problem was i
was drawing the left path
twice that's all it was pretty dumb
pretty stupid error
that's what i get for copying and
pasting and not being thorough the way i
went about actually trying to debug it
was going over to my plug-in processor
and then in my process block function
i'm
going back to using my test oscillator
and i'm clearing the buffer and i'm
writing the oscillators samples to only
one channel particularly the left
channel
and then from there i was just checking
to see like hey is this actually getting
proper audio so it turns out it was
and then after looking at all the other
code that was copied over it literally
was just
me um drawing the left path
twice okay so let me go turn off the
turn off this code right here and then
let's run this in the vst and we should
let's run this in audio plug and host
and we should see
both the left and right channel
all right let's try this again let's try
this again
all right right definitely have a blue
and yellow line that is fantastic that
is fantastic
and if we roll out of the roll off
behind all the behind all the high-end
stuff disappear
same for real for falling off we get to
see our
frequency our frequency responder
[Music]
that get dipped out as well all right
cool all right cool
[Music]
okay so okay so that's the analyzer you
can check that out we can check that off
make a commit of that commit of that
right imprint fft
from spectrum analyzer analyzer
okay let's just stage all this stuff and
commit
okay so the next thing that i want to
add is some bypass buttons for each band
and then a bypass button for the
analyzer because those
analyzers always use a ton of cpu
okay cool
all right time for the bypass buttons
now we have
three bands and thus we need three
boolean parameters to enable bypassing
each individual band and i also want to
be able to turn the analyzer on and off
so we're going to need a boolean
parameter for that
so head on over to your plug-in
processor and go down to where your
parameters are created and we're going
to add
some booleans for this okay layout.add
std make unique
and we want juice audio parameter bool
i'm going to call this guy
low cut bypassed
and a default value of false meaning
that they are not bypassed
all right we're going to do two more of
these for the um
for the parametric band peak band
whatever you want to call it and the
high
cut okay and then one more for the
analyzer to be enabled
and this one's going to be true meaning
the analyzer is enabled by default
okay let's go over to our plugin
processor dot h because
way up near where our chain settings are
defined
we need to supply the bypass states at
the same time so let's add
three boolean flags to represent that
boolean
uh low cut by past false
peak bypassed false and then high
cut bypassed false
let's go back to our plug-in
processor.cpp let's go to where our
um where we get our parameters get chain
settings
this is where we need to grab these guys
now these are boolean parameters
but the parameters are stored as floats
so
if the great if the value is greater
than 0.5
that means it's true so we can do
settings dot low cut
bypass equals then get the parameter
low cut bypassed it's atomic
if it's greater than 0.5
then it is bypassed and do the same
thing for the other two parameters
okay all right let's go to our update
low cut filter function now all we have
to do here before we update the cut
filter
is set that bypass state so left chain
dot set bypassed and then chain position
low cut and then chain settings
low cut bypassed all right do that for
both chains
whoops copy paste
right chain do the exact same thing for
the high cut
all right we want the high cut position
and high cut bypass
and then finally do it for the peak
filters
well let's just copy this copy this line
left chain to set bypass peak
all right that takes care of the dsp our
chains get updated with the bypass
settings
now we just need to add some buttons to
the gui so let's go do that next
head on over to the plugin editor dot h
and we're going to go down to our editor
and we're going to add
um we're gonna add some toggle buttons
okay i'm gonna use toggle button for
right now because we can customize those
visuals later
we can customize those visuals later and
this is just gonna do the job for right
now
all right i did all four low cut peak
high cut and then the analyzer enabled
button
now let's go to our plugin editor dot
cpp we're going to go down to our get
comps function
we're going to add those four buttons
all right now we need to position them
so for this let's go to our resized
function
now i want to give them a height of 25 i
want them to sit above each of these
stack of knobs that we got the stack of
sliders
so we've got our low cut area our high
cut area so at the top of those is where
i'm going to put this okay so let's
do the left side first the low cut low
cut bypass button
set bounds and we're going to do
a low cut area remove from top
25 all right we'll do the same thing for
the high cut
i cut bypass button set bounds
high cut area remove from top
25 and then our peak bypass button
peak bypass button let's set bounds
equals uh bounds dot remove from top
25. cool we are going to do the um
uh we're going to do the analyzer button
in a little bit
but we have these three let's take a
look put it on the
standalone version for right now should
see three buttons right in the middle
um right in centered among the three
rows three columns of but
of sliders and there we go here's our
toggle button
all right cool let's connect them to
parameters next
all right go back to plugineditor.h and
we need to declare some
button attachments so using
button attachment equals ap vts
button attachment and now we can declare
four of them
i'm just gonna copy these guys
and then put attachment at the end if i
put them all in the same line it'll make
it real easy
before i line them all up and i can do
this
cool all right so those are the
attachments we're going to use them the
same way we d
we did with these sliders we just just
need to connect them to the actual
parameters
we go do that in our constructor plug-in
editor
constructor at the end of this list
this is where we need to add the
attachments uh
low-cut bypass button
um it's this thing
it's this thing low cut bypass button
and then the parameter id
is low cut by passed
all right and we need to do this for the
other four buttons even though we're not
showing the analyzer
peak bypass button okay
let's give that a quick build make sure
we don't get any errors
and let's run it to make sure that we
typed our param names correctly
but those should be connected now all
right so
let's run it all right let's run it with
audio plug and host so we can run audio
through it and see if we hear it do
anything
okay so i'm gonna set this up kind of
high run some audio and then bypass
all right so the bypass control
definitely works but the response curve
is not updating
okay let's take care of that next all
right let's head on up to our update
chain function
for the uh response curve component
now we've got our chain settings right
here so we're going to do the same thing
we did with the
process block we're going to update the
bypass states of the chain
accordingly mono chain
set bypassed and then each of the
indexes chain position
low cut chain settings
low cut bypassed all right do that for
the other
two chain positions okay
all right once we've got these bypass
states
um let's go to our paint function
because once we have these bypass states
you know if the chain is not bypassed um
we need to add the magnitude however for
the low cut and
high cut bands even though we bypass the
entire chain
this right here does not check if that
actual link in the in the
greater chain is bypassed so we need to
do that for these guys
we need to do if mono chain dot is
bypassed
all right if the low cut
processor chain is not bypassed then we
can check if the
individual bands are bypassed we can do
the same thing for the high cut
all right let's test it out oh got this
jscert that's happening we'll take care
of that in just a little bit
for some reason the render data is full
of uh
invalid values let's show me my plug-in
gui
all right
all right look at that it does it for
this one
that's bypass
cool let's do it for this guy
[Music]
all right awesome that is working as
expected
all right let's uh make a commit that we
have added bypass buttons
added ability to bypass
dsp bands response
curve follows bypass state
good times all right we can dial in the
graphics next
okay for this we want to use the
toggle button um look and feel function
draw toggle button let me pull up the
documentation for that
so look and feel methods version 4.
let's see these are
slider we want to look for toggle button
where is that where are those look and
feel
member functions you know it's part of
um
the look and feel class okay so we've
got uh draw button text draw a toggle
button draw a tick box
drawable button all that kind of stuff
okay so we want to implement draw toggle
button
so let's go up to our plugin editor.h
let's go to where our look and feel
is declared and we're going to add
this draw toggle button function i'm
just going to grab it from
the documentation
give me some names for these guys
let's put them on there online and then
all these need that
juice namespace before them
okay all right and after these
look nice it would be wise to make the
toggle buttons actually disable the
sliders for whatever band they are
attached
to so that's going to be one of the
things we're going to work on as well
all right we just need to give our
editor a look and feel instance
all right and we need to assign it to
the three bands
we'll do that in our constructor
go down here let's do it after we add
our make our guys come
uh make our guys visible peak bypass
button dot set look and feel
no low cut
and then we need to set these to null
pointer in the destructor
cool all right let's go to
our look and feel implementations
plug plugin editor.cpp go to where that
look and feel implementation is it's way
up at the top
all right let's clean up this space now
right here what i would like to
do what i would like to create for these
toggle buttons is a
power button type of graphic and this
can be accomplished by using the path
function add centered arc now this
function will let us create an arc which
has a notch at the top
and then we just need to add a vertical
bar that goes from the top to the center
and that's it okay it's super easy just
use a
wide stroke type when it's time to fill
the path and it will look like a power
button
so let's do that all right using
namespace juice
because i didn't turn it on in processor
in a producer
that setting is um here by the way if
you go under your gear
then you can do add using namespace
juice to the juiceheader.h it's disabled
by default because
the thought is that it's you're less
likely to get collisions with other
namespace classes
such as the point class which is a
default class on
it's a it's one of the classes that
comes with some of the os x
frameworks so by
turning this off it makes it less likely
that you're going to get those types of
namespace collisions
with your class names okay all right
enough of that uh
let's see path power button okay
first thing first is we're going to
create a rectangle
this rectangle is going to have equal
length sides and in the center of that
will be our
um yeah this rectangle is going to be
um center in our component's bounding
box so let's do that first
uh where's our toggle button we're going
to do that same uh
j min thing that we were talking about
um we did that
up for the um we did that somewhere
somewhere we did a j min so that way our
um one of these rectangles was a square
inside of a non-square bounding box that
right here this is where we did it in
the
get slider bounce okay we're doing that
same thing right here
all right so instead of it being exactly
the
exactly a square in the center of it
we're gonna shrink it a little bit maybe
like
six or so we'll use juice live constant
to figure it out later
maybe maybe we'll do four uh no i'm
gonna go back to six
um if i want to adjust it i can come
back with juice live constant and tweak
it that way
all right then auto r equals um bounds
dot width
size keeping the center so i'm creating
a rectangle with
this size whose center
is the center of our toggle buttons uh
bounding box
all right now let's specify some angles
to make the gap at the top of the arc
okay i am um yeah we're gonna
yeah we're gonna specify some angles to
make the gap at the top of the arc
and then we're going to shrink this
square to be drawing
um we're going to shrink the square just
a little bit
more we'll play around with it and we'll
juice with juice
live constant and you know get it to
look the way we want it to look
so float ang equals 30 dot
f because it's radians because i don't
know how i mean it's degrees because i
don't know how to think in radians
um we'll shrink this size a little bit
maybe just a little bit more we can use
juice live constant later
now let's make our arc power button dot
add centered arc okay so we're going to
center it at
r our radius is going to be half
of the size of our box that we have
size times 0.5 that's radius for both
axes all right we're not rotating this
ellipse at all so that means that 12
o'clock is still gonna be right here
as opposed to if we had rotated it then
it would be like negative 30 goes to
here and plus 30 goes that way
okay so we are going to do zero
for that and then our from radians uh
let's see if this is 12 o'clock
right here at the top i want to go
negative 30.
oh no i want to go 30 this way and then
i want to go
uh 360 minus 30 for the second one
so here we go let's see radians
uh sorry degrees to radians and we've
got 30
all right our angle and then the same
thing degrees 2 radians
uh 360 degrees minus our angle
so if we want we can open this up
and there's no you know we're using
these variables so that way we can
adjust the way these visuals look
and then yeah this says there's
there's an extra let's see power button
dot add centered arc
there's an extra parameter that's not
shown up here
uh start as new sub path so this this is
the parameter i want to add
this should be true all right now let's
make the vertical line
okay power button start new sub path
and this sub path is going to be
it's going to be at the center of our
rectangle but then at the top
and then we can do a simple power button
dot
line to r dot get center
we're going center of our box at the top
y equals zero and then we just go
straight down to the center
all right let's just create a path
stroke type of two
um norm you know normally when you
draw a path you can do uh juice you can
do
g dot draw path or
stroke path like that and then provide a
stroke type that way but i want to
specify some
custom stuff so it will help me if i use
the
um path stroke type constructor
this one right here so i can um use that
joint style
okay so i'm going to use a stroke
thickness of we'll try to
and then for the joint style if i use a
curved joint style it'll give me rounded
edges
at the gap and then around that
rectangle so i'm going to use that
so i'll do curved
all right now this just needs a name pst
and now i can use that here pst and then
the path is going to be the power button
and then what is wrong with this why is
this complaining
oh is that because that needs to be to
float yes
this should be a float rectangle um now
we just need a color
so if the button is
if the button is on we're going to use
one color and otherwise we're going to
use another color
so what that means when the button is on
is that the band is
bypassed okay so that's so if it's
bypassed let's use a gray color
and then if it's not let's use that
green color that we've been using in
other places because it looks cool
all right so let's see auto color equals
button dot get
toggle state oh sorry toggle button i
get toggle state
get the toggle state if it is on meaning
the band is bypassed we're going to use
colors dim gray
otherwise let's go find that green color
i think that's this i should really
standardize that but
you know it's a tutorial i'm not trying
to show the best practices
but i'm trying to show good practices
okay here we go g.set color
color all right so we're going to draw
our path
and then we can draw a uh
draw a circle around the whole thing
once we draw our path
g dot draw ellipse and
we can do r with a line sigma thickness
of two
all right that should look good all
right let's
try that out hey look at that
okay cool so these are currently not
bypassed so i'm going to adjust this and
then do that
so that's cool that works as expected if
it's green it means it's active
if it's gray it means it's not i'm happy
with that
that makes sense well that's kind of
interesting if
as long as we're clicking inside the
bounding box
uh it's gonna toggle it so something
that we could do that i'm not going to
do here
is to set up the hit test region so that
way if you only click
inside this area it says yes you clicked
on me
um if otherwise if you click out of that
no we did not click on you
so for reference um i'm gonna just add a
uh
g dot set color colors red
and then g dot draw erect
just so we can see the bounding box i'm
actually talking about um
bounce so this way you can see what i
mean about if you click outside of it
okay so if we click anywhere in here we
are technically clicking
inside that toggle button okay but we
only want to you know if we
it's not something i'm going to do in
this video but we could
go through and say you know what it's
only when you click inside
this there's a special hit test function
that we can override
and say if we click inside here that
means we actually clicked on the
component if we clicked here we did not
and that's how we can make it only
respond that way but i'm not going to do
that
it's a little bit beyond the scope of
this tutorial
so i'm just going to get rid of that
okay let's um add
a commit for that so customized
um customized the uh graphics
all right before i do that actually i
wanted to show the juice live constant
thing so if we do this here
juice juice live constant this was six
same for this one this was also six and
we can mess with this angle too
um all right so this will be interesting
we can see what that looks like let's
change these numbers move these sliders
we'll get to see what it looks like
all right let's move this out of the way
so we're changing the first one this is
going to make these guys get smaller or
bigger
and obviously once we get past a certain
point they start being drawn outside
their bounding box
now here's where we can adjust the angle
so that's kind of neat all right so i
like where we had it maybe
40 or 40 looks kind of cool maybe a
little bit closer like 25 is good and
then this one
this shrinks that guy a little bit more
so it's like this one changes the whole
thing
and then this one changes that inner arc
all right
so i'm going to leave those where i had
them because i liked that positioning
but you can do that same thing to
adjust the placement of those guys all
right i'll put this back to um
put this back to 30 put this back to six
and put this guy back to six as well
alright cool
let's make that commit all right now
what i want to do is reuse that toggle
button
functionality for the analyzer button as
well let me say that again
what i want to do is reuse this toggle
button
i want to reuse this draw toggle button
functionality for the analyzer button as
well
but what i want to do is switch based
off of the
button type in that draw toggle button
function so i'm going to create two
classes i'm going to go here
in my editor i'm going to do this right
above the editor
i'm going to create two classes that
inherit from toggle button
and that's going to allow me to cast
between the
um it's going to allow me to cast that
uh
let me see let me go up here it's going
to allow me to cast this
argument to determine if it's one of
these two types of buttons
and then i can switch accordingly um
in the actual implementation of that
function uh just follow the code you'll
see what i'm talking about i'm not
explaining it very well here we go
struct power button
juice okay very simple struct
uh analyzer button okay
so that's step one all right step number
two
is to make the bypass buttons uh
we'll make the bypass buttons become
that class power button
and then the analyzer button needs to be
an analyzer button
like that okay very simple
all right now let's go up to our draw
toggle button look and feel
implementation this guy right here all i
need to do is just
cast and everything should work as it
did before okay so i'm just going to
have this
power button path i'm going to cast um
i'm going to make a check and if like i
can cast this
object to a power button type then i'm
going to do all of this
all right if auto
okay so if we run it i'm going to put
this back on the editor
on the standalone version because it
opens a little bit quicker
um we should be able to run it and now
we can add code that draws the analyzer
button
after this is verified all right
sure enough we still have our analyzer
buttons our our bypass buttons
working as expected cool
so let's add our analyzer code um where
is this being added
okay we're going to add our analyzer
code here
now i think it would be cool to see a
randomized path
drawn inside of this button to kind of
you know reflect the fact that it is an
analyzer
so i'm going to use the same color
settings that i used for the power
button
green if something is active and gray if
something is not
in this instance the toggle button will
reflect the opposite state
that it did with the power button which
means i cannot use
this thing i have to flip it around so
let me add an
uh if else or an else if right here to
make sure i have an analyzer button
go faster if you're walking copy this
color line over
and we need to flip that that's all
because
as i said if the toggle button is on
then that means we want to use this
green color otherwise if it's off let's
use the dim gray
all right g dot set color color
okay next i'm going to start by drawing
a normal rectangle
auto bounds now i'm going to shrink it a
little bit
and then i'm going to randomly generate
a path inside of that smaller rectangle
i don't want it to look too crazy so i i
will produce a line segment
every other pixel so let's start with
our path
random path we'll use a random object
and then now we can um start
our random path
we will start it at our inset and our y
position will be in set
rect.get y um
plus inset
height times some random float value
right so our y value is going to be the
top our height is the bottom
so we're going to go remember this is 0
and this is height
so we're going to go 0 down to height
multiply height by some value between 0
and 1 to give us a random height
between the top and the bottom all right
now we just needed
to perform a line to like this for
auto x equals um in set rect
dot get x plus one
x is less than inset rect.get
right plus uh x plus equals two
then we just basically do this
our x position is going to be let's see
this is going to be line two
oh boy line two
get out of here trixie let me just type
this line
random path line two our x is gonna be
x and then our y position is gonna be
this obviously we should pre-cache some
of these positions
because calling get y and get height
every line
you know it's not ideal but whatever we
can
always refactor that type of stuff later
okay now let's just draw the path
let's use a thickness of one all right
that should do it
let's get our analyzer button on the
screen and using this look and feel so
we can tweak this
if needed head on down to
our uh editor constructor
let's provide that look and feel
analyzer enabled button
set look and feel all right and don't
forget to
disable it all right now i'm going to
stick this
right at the top of
the gui on the left so let's see
i'm gonna go like this i'm gonna go um
auto analyzer enabled area equals bounds
dot remove from top
give me the top 25 pixels just a whole
row
25 pixels wide 25 pixels tall from the
very top
okay now i'm going to do uh analyzer
enabled
area dot give me a width of 10
of um 100
give me an x of five so it's not uh
right along that edge
and then um give me just remove a little
bit from the top of this analyzer
enabled area so there's a gap between
the top of the gui and the top of this
rectangle
all right now i'm just going to set
that to be my analyzer enabled buttons
bounds
and let me give myself a little bit of a
gap between the analyzer button and the
analyzer itself and let's see what it
looks like
bounce.remove from top five
okay so we should expect to see a
squiggly line
just like that all right okay this is
neat so whenever we mouse over it
it repaints and it produces a new
path so let's make the path be a member
variable of the class that is computed
only once
whenever the instance is resized so we
know that our
random path creation process works which
is cool so we're just going to use that
to make this path all right let's do
that next
all right let's add a commit for this
analyzer button is visible
path is created every time
it repaints all right let's head on over
to our
declaration for that class there was
here analyzer button
all right so let's set this up with a
resized function
this is where we will compute the random
path that the toggle button
will draw so let's see void resized
override all right we're going to need
those bounding box
we're going to need that bounding box
auto bounds equals get local bounce
we're still going to need to shrink it
and then instead of creating a new
random path
we're just going to clear the existing
one let's add that as a member variable
juice path random
all right so random path dot clear
it's gonna clear it and then let's go
grab our um
other code that drew that thing that's
way up here
that look and feel stuff where is that
this stuff
all right let's just copy this comment
it out
plug an editor paste that right here
okay
here's our juice random except it needs
to be a juice random
all right there's our random path start
new sub path
same line two code that we had before
all right let's go back to our plugin
editor
okay so the stuff we need to discard is
the inset
rect the random path we can
get rid of that and now for this we need
to
write analyzer button
oh boy random path like that
okay so we're just going to draw that
path member variable directly
all right let's run it and see what we
get
all right cool so it's only changing
right now let's open
it only changed once when we use the
standalone let's open
this guy i'm going to run it in audio
plug and host
and see what happens when we open and
close the gui okay
so there's like an m right on this right
edge
let's see what happens when we close
this gui all right that's kind of neat
so every time we open and close the gui
uh we get a new path which is you know
it's kind of neat
okay so the next thing to do is to make
these buttons
um actually disable elements in the gui
all right when we click on this we want
these sliders to stop working when we
click on this
we don't want to see the fft happen in
the background okay we will do those
next let's leave this open
all right let's get rid of this code and
make a commit
uh analyzer path
button analyzer button path is
created only once all right now if we
were real sticklers about
making it only appear once every time
the gui is opened
what we could do is store
this path um it could become not an
audio parameter but it could be stored
in the audio parameter
value tree state state value tree it
could be stored as like just binary data
and then that way whenever the plugin is
first created you get a customized path
and whenever you load that in it just it
gets stored with the plugin
so that's you know that's a way to make
it not have um not be
it's random the very first time you open
the gui but that's the only time once
you
um you have to create a new instance of
the class or a new instance of the
plugin
in order to get a new path there but you
know this is this is cool
all right um let's see what are we going
to do we are going to make our buttons
actually enable or disable gui
parameters next okay
head on over to the audio processor
editor constructor
and we're going to go down to after our
look and feel has been set
now we are going to use the on click
lambdas to change the enablement of the
sliders
so the reason i'm doing this here is
because
this is where all of these components
can see each other
right i'm going to make this button
control
this button is gonna control this slider
and this slider
this button is gonna control these three
sliders
this button is going to control uh
the high cut buttons this guy and this
guy and then this thing is gonna
send a message to this thing to stop
drawing um the analyzer
okay so that's why we're doing this here
instead of like
inside um maybe we make some macro
component that calls
that owns the um the sliders and stuff
i'm doing it here because this is where
the the most common place this
this is the place where all the
components can see all the other
components
so it makes just the communication
between them easier
now as with all asynchronous callbacks
we need to use a safe pointer to make
sure that our class
in this case the editor is still in
existence when we try to use this
particular on click lambda
all right so let's get started with that
auto safe
pointer equals juice component
safe pointer simple eq audio processor
editor
this all right now we can start
declaring these guys so we'll do we'll
start with the peak
peak bypass button and this is where it
wants a lambda
lambda with no arguments and here's
where we're going to do the good stuff
okay
first we have to check if our safe
pointer exists
so if auto
all right if it does once we know it
exists we can get the bypass state
and set our slider's enablement
accordingly so auto bypassed
equals comp peak bypass button to get
toggle state
easy all right now remember if the band
is bypassed that means the sliders
should not be enabled or said in reverse
if the band is not bypassed the sliders
should be enabled so comp
um peak frequency slider set enabled
it should be enabled if we are not
bypassed
okay let's do it again for the other
sliders
this is the peak gain and the peak
quality all right let's test it before
we make the other bypass
buttons work all right we did the peak
one
i'm not seeing it do anything hmm
let's go up to our look and feel all
right so here's our draw rotary slider
what are we not doing uh we are not
setting our colors differently
if we are enabled or disabled so let's
go up and do that next
all right we can do that right here auto
enabled equals uh slider dot is enabled
now we can set these colors accordingly
so if we are enabled
use this cool color otherwise use um
let's go the dark gray
that's for the background circle same
thing here
enabled if it's enabled use
that um i guess there's an orangey color
it's the border
um so we will do colors a different type
of gray
all right do we have any other colors
that are displayed in here
looking for set color that's for the
text
all right let's try that out one more
time
there it goes awesome
okay so i would like the parameter text
to
also fade out but we can do that after
we get these other lambdas set
up so we're going to follow the same
pattern
let's go back down to our constructor
we're going to follow the same pattern
we're going to capture a safe pointer
we're going to check if the component is
valid and then if it is we will get the
bypass state and then change the
enablement
of the sliders accordingly so let's do
the low cut
next look at bypass button.on click
all right first make sure the component
is valid if it is get the
bypass state all right this is the low
cut bypass button
and then set the um set the low cut
frequency slider
remember it should be enabled if our
button is
not bypassed okay
and then same thing for the high cut
all right let's give that a test and see
what's going on see if it's working as
expected
this is high cut high cut high cut low
cut low cut low cut
okay all right
awesome cool let's add a commit for
that oh i forgot to make i forgot to
commit these guys
all right those let me say um let's see
bypass buttons toggle
slider enablements that's what happened
there and then also
um yeah that's all part of that same
thing
all right our next step is to make the
analyzer button
toggle the um fft analysis the spectrum
analyzer
see if that make that do something
all right so let's go right here we're
going to do
analyzer enabled button on click
i'm going to capture the same safe
pointer
if auto comp equals
safepointer.getcomponent
all right now we need our enabled state
all right and now let's call a function
that doesn't exist yet
um we'll add it in just a second comp
response curve component dot
toggle analysis enablement
uh enable okay let's that's a good name
for what this function needs to do
all right let's head on over to our
um header file uh editor.h
and provide that function so we stop
having that warning
okay that's um where is that here's our
response curve component
so void bool
enabled okay
and now um let's see what do we need to
do we need to have a flag
that it can check so let's put that down
here at the bottom
should show fft analysis
we'll set that to true by default and
then uh we'll just do an implementation
in class
should show fft analysis equals
enabled nice and simple
all right let's head on over to our
plugin editor.cpp
head over to the um
paint function and uh that's the wrong
paint function response curve paint
function
and if our analyzer is enabled
grab those paths and draw them if
should show fft analysis
do this here's where the paths are drawn
put that right in there all right let's
test it out
oh before we test it out um we should
not
uh if we are where's our timer callback
for this guy
all right if our analysis is turned off
don't do this stuff
all right if we should show the analysis
process
um yeah the fft guys should the
path producers should um produce the
path
all right now we can go test it
all right let's run some audio through
our plug-in and check out that button
[Music]
[Applause]
all right cool that is working
awesome so analyzer enablement button
talk is implemented implemented
analyzer enablement button
i redid that there and did it here
cool all right the last tweak that i
want to do
um let's head on up to the top we're
going to head up to our drop rotary
slider i had said i wanted that text
uh to be um adjusted
all right so let's do that right now um
yeah okay so right here if we're enabled
um
use the black background otherwise use a
dark gray background
and then if we are enabled use white
text
otherwise use light gray text
all right let's see what that looks like
hey awesome all right i'm very happy
with that
okay cool all right let's make a commit
of that
tweaked uh button text when
enabled or disabled
all right that is the end of the
tutorial i am going to dial in the
graphics a little bit more
but there you have it that is how to
build the simple eq
thanks for sticking with me to the end
um well we learned how to make this
simple three-panned
3-band equalizer with fft analyzer
if you liked what you experienced here
you can check out my course project 11
where you will learn to build the
project 11
plugin from scratch i also have a course
that teaches c
plus from scratch in the context of
writing audio software the focus there
is on mentorship
and not on video tutorials programming
is learned by doing not by watching
so for that you're going to work your
way through 10
10 projects i'm going to review your
code every step of the way via pull
requests on github and bitbucket
because that's what we use in the real
world um nine of them are pure c-plus
plus
projects that will teach you the
language fundamentals uh the tenth
project is a multi-meter audio plug-in
written in juice
just like we used here it features level
meters
histograms go neometers correlation
meters
buttons and combo boxes threshold
sliders
saving and loading the plug-and-stay and
a little bit of the dsp
basically what you experienced here but
with way more visual stuff being built
and you aren't watching me build it
either okay you are
building it on your own i take on the
role of your project manager
i set up a jira board with all of the
instructions because that's how
companies
manage projects in the real world i
assign you issues from that board you
tackle them i review your work
and either help you when you get stuck
or i approve it and assign you something
new
uh in the end you'll have built the
whole plug-in from scratch without me
writing a single line of code for you
you're going to do it all yourself i'm
just there when you need help
so it's a pretty cool experience i've
had a lot of people uh go through it
i've had a few people actually manage to
land jobs at some
pretty big audio company so check out
the link in the description or by
visiting
www.programmingformusicians.com
thank you again for tuning in i am chuck
i also go by the name matcat music on
instagram and youtube
good luck on your coding journeys and i
will see you in the next project
[Applause]
[Music]
you